Monsieur le Secrétaire général monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
débutons cet après-midi des auditions de
la mission d'information que notre
commission a décidé de constituer sur la
création du fond Marianne la sélection
des projets subventionnés le contrôle de
leur exécution et les résultats obtenus
au regard des objectifs du fond
cette mission d'information a obtenu du
Sénat de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes
monsieur Gravel vous êtes préfet
secrétaire général du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation plus
communément connu sous le l'appellation
cipdr
à ce titre vous avez eu la Charre en
charge de l'organisation de l'appel à
projet au titre du fond Marianne et le
suivi de sa mise en œuvre votre audition
est donc particulièrement attendue pour
bien comprendre le fonctionnement de ce
fond
avant de vous donner la parole pour un
bref propos liminaire dans lequel je
vous propose d'évoquer les conditions de
votre arrivée au secrétariat général
ainsi que la chronologie initiale
conduisant à l'annonce de l'appel à
projets je tiens à rappeler quelques
éléments tout d'abord notre mission
d'information dotée donc des
prérogatives de commission d'enquête
comprend tous les membres de la
commission des finances qui pourront
donc seul intervenir lors de cette
audition pour vous interroger
cette audition est par ailleurs diffusée
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié
ensuite par respect pour la famille de
l'enseignant assassiné le 16 octobre
2020 et sa mémoire je vous propose mes
chers collègues que nous gardions
d'évoquer nous gardions d'évoquer son
nom à l'appui de nos questionnements qui
se concentreront sur l'objet de notre
enquête à savoir le fonctionnement du
fond Marianne
je tiens par ailleurs à vous indiquer
que Monsieur le gardisso a confirmé à
monsieur le Président du Sénat
l'existence d'une information judiciaire
en lien avec le fond Marianne sans
préciser toutefois ni la nature ni le
périmètre des poursuites engagées
si cela nous permet de travailler nous
devrons néanmoins rester prudents pour
ne pas interférer avec cette procédure
il ne nous reviendra en particulier à
aucun moment mais vous le comprenez de
qualifier l'effet qui nous sont soumis
en référence à des infractions pénales
ce qui relèverait de la compétence
exclusive de l'autorité judiciaire
enfin je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête et
passible de sanctions pénales qui
peuvent aller selon les circonstances de
3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45 à
100.000 euros d'amende
je vous invite Monsieur le Secrétaire
général a prêté serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levait la main
droite et dites je le jure
je vous laisse donc maintenant à présent
la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs au moment où s'ouvre la
première audition de votre commission
d'enquête je souhaiterais d'abord vous
faire part de mon soulagement
depuis bientôt deux mois beaucoup de
choses ont été dites écrites sur le fond
Marianne
des hypothèses des allégations
des mensonges assez souvent des
calomnies trop souvent
il appartient désormais à votre
commission mais aussi à l'inspection
générale de l'administration et la
justice d'établir la vérité
cette vérité est d'autant plus
nécessaire aujourd'hui que tous les
ennemis de la République
font leur miel de contre vérité pour
tenter de mettre à bas une politique
publique majeure et tous ceux qui la
mettent en œuvre
au cours de ces
dernières semaines le cipdr a dû suivre
l'émergence le développement et les
rebondissements de ce dossier en restant
à distance aujourd'hui la situation est
différente votre exigence d'une
prestation de serment engage autant
qu'elle libère
cette audition m'offre enfin
l'opportunité de m'exprimer pleinement
clairement sur les faits incriminés et
je répondrai donc à toutes vos questions
le plus précisément possible mais
permettez-moi au préalable d'ouvrir
notre échange par de très brèves
considérations générales en premier lieu
je tiens à préciser quelques mots ce
qu'est le cipdr créé en 2006 sa
structure est placée sous l'autorité du
ministère de l'Intérieur et dépendait à
l'époque des faits de la ministre
délégué chargé de la citoyenneté lors de
sa création son périmètre était limité à
la prévention de la délinquance puis les
compétences du cpdr n'ont cessé de
s'élargir trois missions essentielles à
la sécurité de nos concitoyens se sont
ajoutés la prévention de la
radicalisation
en 2014 la lutte contre les séparatismes
en 2019 la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires et la création d'une unité de
contrediscours républicain en 2020 pour
accompagner cette extension les
effectifs du cipdr ont doublé entre 2020
et 2021 mais il ne rassemble je le
précise aujourd'hui qu'une soixantaine
de TP au moment où le cpdr apprend le
lancement d'un fond Marianne
ces agents sont alors mobilisés sur cinq
chantiers majeurs ils doivent d'abord
développer l'unité de contreditours
chargé d'analyser et de riposter en
ligne ils doivent ensuite déployer la
stratégie nationale de lutte contre les
séparatistes en accompagnant l'ensemble
des préfectures
il doit vous aussi décliner avec chacune
d'elles la nouvelle stratégie nationale
de prévention de la délinquance ils
doivent encore redoubler d'efforts en
matière de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires et elles doivent enfin
préparer avec le parquet national
antiterroriste et la DGSI le suivi des
mineurs de retour de zones de Syrie
ou sinon nombreuses qu'essentiels ses
missions ont été portées par une équipe
extrêmement investie
déployée sur tous les fronts le cpdr
accomplit chaque jour ses missions à
flux tendu
je souhaite donc devant vous saluer
l'engagement de mes équipes malgré la
surcharge de travail elles ont réagi
comme il se devaient et je me permets au
passage de souligner également leur
courage
à plusieurs reprises nous avons fait
l'objet de menaces et l'une d'entre
elles a été considérée par les services
compétents comme étant particulièrement
sérieuse
je reviens maintenant à ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui en premier lieu je
crois essentiel d'expliquer
l'opportunité des actions engagées dans
le cadre du fond Marianne
suite aux attentats qui ont frappé la
France fin 2020 les autorités publiques
ont jugé nécessaire de renforcer les
moyens mobiliser pour prévenir les
processus de radicalisation sur la toile
complexe et multiformes ces phénomènes
ont pour base commune le rejet des
principes qui font de notre société et
pour horizon possible le basculement
dans le terrorisme
défendre les valeurs de la République
sur le web c'est donc agir aux
avant-postes le djihadisme ce n'est pas
seulement le terrorisme c'est aussi la
transmission d'idées la volonté
d'imposer une vision du monde un modèle
de société en opposition frontale avec
la République avec la démocratie
recours au secteur associatif parce que
sa parole est inaudible auprès des
personnes les plus vulnérables au
processus de radicalisation
conséquence d'une crise durable de
l'autorité bien sûr se discrédit est
aujourd'hui aggravé par le déploiement
exponentiel des thèses complotistes sur
Internet surmonter la défiance de nos
concitoyens les plus sceptiques exigent
donc de mobiliser des acteurs de
proximité dont le capital confiance est
encore intacte et les modes d'expression
adaptés la mobilisation du secteur
associatif est donc un levier essentiel
pour déployer sur internet un discours
républicain crédible mais rares sont les
associations qui sont en mesure à la
fois d'agir contre le séparatisme et de
maîtriser les techniques de la
communication digitale
malgré la promotion faite lors du
lancement de l'appel à projet le cpda
n'a reçu que 73 candidatures rappelant
qu'il y a un tissu associatif d'un
million d'entités en France
pour bien comprendre les choix fait et
les problèmes rencontrés dans
l'utilisation de ces crédits il est
capital d'avoir en tête que le réseau
associatif est très faiblement développé
sur ce créneau alors oui en toute
logique dans un écosystème aux
dimensions aussi réduites les uns et les
autres finissent souvent par se
rencontrer parce ce croiser pour avoir
travaillé sur des sujets identiques pour
avoir débattu à l'occasion de coloc
collaborer à des missions communes les
différents spécialistes et protagonistes
de la prévention de la radicalisation
ont pour beaucoup appris à se connaître
au fil des années et la faible densité
du secteur associatif est-elle qu'elle a
impacté l'enveloppe du fond Marianne
faute d'avoir reçu suffisamment de
dossiers répondants aux objectifs
décisions ont été prises comme vous le
savez de diminuer significativement son
budget
en passant de 2 millions et demi d'euros
à 2 millions 17600 euros
enfin si l'on veut évaluer les actions
du cpdr il faut garder à l'esprit que le
fond Marianne reposer sur le régime
juridique des subventions pas sur celui
de la commande publique
distinguer ces deux mécanismes est
essentiels cela est évidemment en
portent des conséquences déterminantes
dans les modalités d'attribution et de
contrôle de l'argent public nous y
reviendrons sans aucun doute pour
conclure je souhaiterais souligner que
les initiatives prises par les pouvoirs
publics en matière de contreditours dans
notre pays comme dans bien d'autres en
Europe notamment relève encore de
l'expérimentation il s'agit d'un champ
qui est nouveau
et comme pour toute expérimentation
certaines tentatives restent incertaines
la marge d'erreur quelle que soit les
précautions prises ne peut jamais être
réduite à zéro et c'est bien sûr le rôle
du cpdr à l'époque avec le cabinet de la
ministre de veiller c'était son rôle de
veiller à ce que les candidats soient
retenus sur les meilleurs à ce que
l'argent confié soit bien employé à ce
que les résultats obtenus soient
précisément évalués dans le cadre du
fond Marianne 17 associations donc sur
73 ont finalement été sélectionnés pour
bénéficier de ces subventions le bilan
global est positif
cela n'a jamais été dit
au final ce soutien financier de l'État
a permis de diffuser auprès de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'internautes dont
358 000 abonnés plus de 2000
publications en tout genre des postes
d'extraites des tweets des vidéos ou des
podcasts des outils pédagogiques
générant au total plus de 6 millions
d'impressions sur les réseaux sociaux
pour défendre notre modèle républicain
les interrogations et certains constats
concernant deux associations en tâche la
démarche
nous nous y attarderons bien avant la
mobilisation médiatique le cpdr a pris
plusieurs mesures pour répondre aux
dysfonctionnements des partenaires en
tirer les enseignements renforcer les
moyens de contrôle et finalement saisir
le procureur il appartiendra à votre
commission d'apprécier entre autres
choses
si l'action du cpdr a été à la hauteur
des missions confiées je suis donc à
votre entière disposition pour répondre
à l'ensemble de vos questions
merci Monsieur le Secrétaire général
monsieur le rapporteur merci Monsieur
secrétaire général on va s'attacher à
reprendre la chronologie des faits et
point par point la manière de dont vous
avez procédé je voudrais d'abord savoir
et que vous nous rappeliez qui a été à
l'initiative de la création du fond
Marianne cette création a-t-elle été
débattue au sein de du secrétariat
général du
comité interministériel de la prévention
de la délinquance et si oui sur quel sur
quels aspects apporter le débat que ce
soit sur des sujets d'objectifs
poursuivis de montant de fonds et sur
question de quel organisation
ce projet est le fruit de la volonté
politique
celle de la ministre délégué chargé de
les citoyenneté de l'époque qui a fait
savoir au cipdr à travers son cabinet
que ce projet ambitieux devait être
engagé il n'y a donc pas eu de
d'échanges de discussions avec
l'administration pour envisager de
déterminer les contours de ce projet par
contre il a été demandé naturellement
l'administration ayant notamment charge
le suivi du FIPD le fond
interministériel de prévention la
délinquance sur lequel se greffer le
fond Marianne le fond Marianne en fait
porte à confusion c'est un label de
communication d'informations il s'agit
en fait d'une partie de l'enveloppe du
programme r programme radicalisation
issus du FIPD avec des plombiers 2
millions 17 600 euros qui ont été
déployés qui ont été ponctionnés dans le
cadre de ce projet et donc pour répondre
à votre question monsieur rapporteur
précisément donc il s'agit d'une
commande politique
issue de la ministre concernée il n'y
avait pas eu de préparation d'analyses
en amont avant d'engager le travail qui
a été demandé à l'administration voilà
donc j'ai bien compris comment politique
et l'administration s'exécute pouvez
peut-être maintenant nous dire comment a
été défini le cahier des charges de
l'appel à projet
quelle a été le calendrier de celui-ci
et en particulier puisque vous avez
évoqué le peu de réponse 73 sur un
million mais de d'associations mais il y
a eu un délai très court puisque trois
semaines pour répondre ce délai vous
paraît-il avoir été suffisant pour
permettre
au monde associatif et aux associations
de présenter un projet qui soit ou des
projets qui soient suffisamment
structurés après que le pour faire la
transition après que le cabinet nous est
informé de ce projet dans la location
d'une réunion bilatérale qui réunissait
de manière hebdomadaire le cabinet et le
cpdr nous avons également évoqué le
sujet à l'occasion d'un ce qu'on appelle
un comité de programmation le 13 avril
2021 instance pendant laquelle
avec le cabinet et le cpdr
pendant qu'elle est décidé la nature des
associations pouvant bénéficier de
subventions leur montant avec toujours
par définition une validation politique
portée par par le cabinet c'était cette
occasion là que
nous apprenons également qu'un certain
nombre d'associations
qui avait été qui avait postulé pour
bénéficier de subventions pourraient
potentiellement
glisser vers le fond Marianne donc on a
confirmation en ce moment-là qu'il y a
bien un appel à projet qui va
s'organiser dans les jours dans les
semaines qui viennent et qu'il faut
envisager de lancer cet appel à projet
nous y travaillons nous travaillons sur
un document qui était élaboré par une
chargée de mission qui était déjà
spécialisée sur ces questions de
contrediscours sociétal depuis quelques
années avant même bien avant que le fond
Marianne soit engagé
et sous couvert de sa responsable de
service évidemment après ma validation
nous proposons un projet d'appel à
projet au cabinet qui est validé et qui
est diffusé au lendemain de l'annonce
formelle publique par la ministre
délégué à l'occasion d'une interview
médiatique le 20 le 20 mai
pardon le 20 avril
et au lendemain donc nous engageons nous
diffusons ce document invitant
l'ensemble du tissu associatif
potentiellement intéressés ou concerné à
s'inscrire dans cette démarche là
je vais je vais être sûr d'avoir bien
compris puisque vous avez vous venez
nous expliquer que c'était une commande
du cabinet et que par la réunion du 13
avril avec notamment le cabinet n'est
pas exclusivement vous avez compris oui
vous avez été dit que des associations
allaient comment dirais-je répondre à
l'appel à projet c'est à dire qu'ils
étaient déjà où elles avaient déjà été
informés
pour quelle raison
certaines associations parce que
peut-être vous aviez identifié des
compétences quelles associations
et de quelle manière c'est
ces informations vous ont été
communiqués en quoi avait-elle été
identifiée avant même le dépôt la
déclaration officielle de l'appel à
projet le 20 avril la demande qui avait
été faite par le cabinet était de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse mobiliser
l'ensemble de la sphère associative à
travers ce projet là
et à l'occasion d'un comité de
programmation
un certain nombre d'associations trois
exactement avaient été fléchés
considérant que ces associations qui
avaient postulé pour bénéficier de
subventions publiques comme ça se fait
très régulièrement nous recevons des
dizaines de demandes de subvention par
an que certaines associations pourraient
potentiellement
concerner directement le fond Marianne
étant donné la nature des projets qui
étaient déposés vous pouvez me citer les
puisque vous dites trois associations
l'uspm
France fraternité et fraternité générale
ensuite un calendrier pour continuer à
répondre à votre question a été élaborée
il s'agissait faire en sorte que il
puisse avoir entre le 20 mai et le 20
avril et le 10 mai le dépôt des
candidatures sachant que nous avions
proposé un autre calendrier avec mon
équipe nous considérions que pour
effectuer ce travail dans des conditions
optimales
il fallait prévoir un calendrier ces
talents sur trois mois du 1er mai à la
fin juillet
le cabinet a demandé à ce que le temps
soit accéléré et qu'on puisse envisager
toute la procédure sur cinq semaines on
en arrive au calendrier que vous
connaissez je suppose que je rappelais à
l'instant avec un dépôt des candidatures
entre le vin avril et le 10 mai et
ensuite l'analyse des dossiers puis un
comité de sélection qui devait se réunir
le le 20 mai au plus tard
on peut je pense qu'on peut comprendre
la demande politique d'aller vite
d'accélérer étant donné le contexte de
l'époque il faut quand même se projeter
deux ans en arrière nous étions à
quelques mois d'une vague d'attentat
aussi insupportable que choquante par
définition et qui avait mobilisé
l'ensemble des acteurs qui avaient
évidemment choqué l'opinion publique et
on peut comprendre qu'il y ait une
volonté je pense même qu'il faut le
saluer contrairement à la critique qui
est faite à l'état d'une manière
générale encore une fois se saisir de se
souiller de ce dossier j'en parlais dans
mes propos liminaires qui est
fondamental de travailler à la base du
processus de radicalisation à travers
Internet qui est devenu aujourd'hui
l'un des canals majeurs de diffusion
d'un certain nombre d'idées en tirés
républicaines assistant parfois même à
la violence et donc on peut comprendre
je pense cette demande d'accélération en
tout cas sachez que nous avions demandé
que c'est noté que cette opération
s'étale sur un délai un peu plus long
c'est un point effectivement c'est un
point important et un point important de
compréhension vous nous dites vous nous
dites que vous avez été finalement saisi
définitivement de la question par une
réunion le 13 avril
et le 20 avril il y a un cahier des
charges qui sort c'est
là on est plus dans la vitesse on est
dans quelque chose de
quasi c'est incroyable je veux dire que
je voudrais vous renvoyer non d'abord je
voudrais comprendre ça 13 20 avril je
veux bien qu'on soit rapide mais on est
au-delà de la vitesse vous le savez bien
le temps de faire le tour de d'une
question de temps d'approfondir les
points importants qu'est-ce qu'on
demande à ces associations on est quand
même pas sur un sujet vous l'a dit
vous-même très facile très
travaillé par les associations donc si
on veut avoir un cahier des charges un
peu solide une semaine ça paraît
extrêmement court et puis je voudrais
vous renvoyer d'un côté vous me dites
vous nous dites bon c'est sans doute
utile il faut se replacer dans l'époque
nous le faisons
nous le faisons vous êtes pu voir que
dans ma conférence de presse je disais
ça c'est à dire que faut se remettre
dans la période évidemment et en même
temps vous nous dites je reprends votre
mot label de communication
pour le format
ces deux idées un peu
complexes à manier d'une part l'idée
qu'il faudrait faire quelque chose parce
qu'il y a un problème et qu'il faut agir
et de l'autre le label de communication
qui est simplement de dire et on y
reviendra d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire les
choses autrement avec des outils qui
existaient comme le FIP des on aurait pu
travailler là-dessus est-ce que vous
pouvez nous ressaisir ces deux points
comment vous les lier bien sûr une
semaine c'est très court je vous le
confirme
la chargée de mission qui connaissait
déjà tous ces sujets
particulièrement bien qu'il est maîtrisé
étant donné qu'elle travaillait sur ce
champ depuis des années à cette impliqué
à temps plein sur cette mission avec le
soutien bien évidemment encore une fois
et ça hiérarchie d'autres agents
notamment du pôle administratif et
financier mais il y avait un agent qui
faisait que ça à 100% à partir du moment
où ce projet nous a été n'a été porté à
notre à notre connaissance
qu'il s'agissait d'élaborer oui cahier
des charges et puis derrière de pouvoir
proposer ce qu'est ce qu'on a fait et
c'est ce que vous retrouvez d'ailleurs
dans les pièces et ce qui ont retrouvé
encore aujourd'hui sur le site internet
du cpdr on peut peut-être là aussi
rentrer tout de suite aussi sur un
certain nombre de sujets il est évident
que après sur le d'accord non mais alors
ok je me garde ça pour pour tout à
l'heure mais pour quand il prolonger la
réponse parce que ça me paraît important
par rapport à ce que vous disiez ensuite
le deuxième élément que vous évoquez qui
n'est pas de malentendu quand je parle
d'un label de communication ça renvoie
pas simplement la communication dans ce
cas le plus caricatural
c'est aussi l'avantage d'avoir de mon
point de vue engagé un projet comme
celui-ci c'était précisément à travers
la forme d'un appel à projet avec toute
la souplesse juridique de ce type
d'opération c'était précisément de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse à travers aussi le
régime juridique de subventions et toute
sa souplesse faire émerger une offre de
service faire en sorte que
des acteurs qui n'étaient pas connus de
la sphère étatique puisse rappel à la
porte avec des idées des propositions
qui fait toutes justement la richesse de
ce type d'opération dans le bon sens du
terme c'est à dire faire en sorte que je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure dans mon
introduction on est confronté à un
écosystème associatif qui est très
restreint le cpdr travaille déjà depuis
des années sur ces questions là
prévention la radicalisation au sens
large depuis 2015 et il est vrai que on
retrouve assez régulièrement les mêmes
acteurs et donc il me semble pas du tout
absurde d'envisager de faire savoir
qu'il y avait
ces subventions proposées par l'État
pour justement accompagner ce travail de
fond concernant la lutte la prévention
de la lutte contre ces problématiques
séparatiste et de radicalisation
sur le web puisque aujourd'hui c'est
encore une fois essentiellement là que
l'opinion se construit c'est devenu
l'espace de socialisation par excellence
donc tous ces éléments légitimes le fait
d'envisager ce type d'action donc c'est
pour ça quand je parle la belle de
bien précis c'était pour bien expliquer
qu'il y a on est dans du droit commun il
y a un fond qui est le fond
intermédiaire de prévention la
délinquance il y a pas un fond nouveau
qui a été créé avec de l'argent qui
viendrait d'une saison j'ai lu et relu
un certain d'absurdité ici ou là je
profite de l'opportunité qui avait faite
pour essayer de tout recadrer dans la
mesure du possible donc tout ça
s'inscrivait dans le FIPD et donc ce
n'est pas un fond au sens juridique du
terme mais c'est dans ce sens là que
j'évoquais l'idée d'un label de
communication qui permettait de faire
savoir qu'il y avait cette opération qui
était lancée je crois était légitime
voilà je vais donner la parole au
rapporteur mais justement là dessus
au moment où se font élancer le 20 avril
on parle pas je crois du FIPD on parle
du fond Marianne c'est à dire on
communique sur le fond Marianne on ne
dit pas c'est une partie du FIPD
c'est tout ça est extrêmement flou sur
en fait est-ce que c'est un fond nouveau
est-ce que c'est voilà je veux le
resituer parce que c'est un des un des
sujets finalement ou un des soucis que
l'on a c'est qu'en fait on est vous
l'avez dit et on l'avait bien noté on y
reviendra d'ailleurs quand on parlera un
peu plus loin de chiffres mais on est
bien sur le fond traditionnel et sur
comment dire un éclairage particulier
donné sur une action particulière de
Somme d'accord exactement
je voulais revenir sur
un des éléments que vous nous avez
communiqué vous êtes en contact à la
demande du cabinet
avez-vous dit alors quel est votre ou
quels sont vos contacts c'est le
directeur de cabinet qui
comment dirais-je vous donne les les
instructions pour développer de manière
effectivement très très rapide le fond
Marianne et l'appel à projet nous avions
4 interlocuteurs
fléchés au cabinet sur toutes les
questions du cipdr du manière générale
et également sur ce projet le fond
Marianne le directeur de cabinet le
conseiller spécial mais également deux
chargés de mission qui suivaient
attentivement l'ensemble des dossiers du
cpdr voilà donc nous avions nous étions
en contact régulier à travers
formellement à travers les réunions
bilatérales hebdomadaires et très
régulièrement pour pas dire
quotidiennement
par mail ou par téléphone en fonction
des sujets en fonction de l'actualité
vous l'avez indiqué plusieurs
associations étaient d'ores et déjà
financés par le fond interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance a été connu
totalement depuis d'ailleurs des fois
2018 enfin on a des actions un peu
longues par rapport à un sujet nouveau
finalement
est-ce que est-ce que vous diriez
que éventuellement la subvention
accordée au titre se font ces substituer
d'une certaine façon à celle qui était
déjà versée
antérieurement d'une année sur l'autre
est-ce qu'on a changé l'appellation mais
est-ce que finalement c'est de la même
action que l'on parlait autrement dit
une association financière en 2020 puis
financé par le fond Marc par le fi BD r
puis ensuite par le fond Marianne est-ce
que finalement c'était une façon pour
elle de poursuivre l'action et
d'afficher une continuité de l'action
sur ces associations où y a-t-il eu
vraiment des montants très sustentiels
nouveaux par rapport à des actions
nouvelles je précise le sujet toutes les
associations ne travaillaient pas sur le
domaine concerné mais certaines oui
c'est-à-dire travailler déjà sur la
question du web comment faire passer les
messages etc donc par rapport à celle là
est-ce que finalement c'est pas un
changement d'appellation mais au fond
bon ça existe déjà on a les deux cas de
figures monsieur le Président nous
avions des associations qui
travaillaient déjà sur ce type de sujet
c'est particulier je vous rappelle vous
le savez que la moitié des bénéficiaires
on y reviendra sans doute après sur les
17 étaient déjà connus du cpdr je vous
renvoie ce que j'évoque depuis le début
sur l'écosystème assez réduit donc nous
connaissions déjà une partie de ces
acteurs au passage constitue un gage de
confiance évident lorsqu'on a pu
travailler avec des acteurs associatifs
ont démontré leur solidité leur rigueur
et leur et leur efficacité évidemment
l'occasion de pouvoir prolonger ce
partenariat à cette occasion mais comme
je le disais aussi précédemment l'idée
c'est aussi de faire émerger de nouveaux
acteurs et donc là pour le coup en temps
normal peut-être que ces acteurs
n'auraient pas effectué une démarche une
procédure pour bénéficier d'une
subvention donc vous avez d'un côté oui
un certain nombre d'associations qui
étaient déjà engagés dans ce terrain là
qui ont continué le travail une certaine
manière qu'on peut le faire évoluer
qu'on peut aussi donner peut-être plus
d'ampleur et puis vous aviez et c'était
ça aussi quand même l'essentiel de ce
fond Marianne l'idée encore une fois de
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs avec
lesquels nous n'avions jamais eu
l'occasion de travailler jusque jusqu'à
présent avec l'idée et c'était la
volonté politique
portée à l'époque faire en sorte que
voilà on y on y apporte ces significatif
alors la base était demi et demi même si
ça s'est fini avec 2 millions et
quelques mais
dans ce domaine là ça signifie dans ce
domaine est significatif bien sûr et
encore une fois sur le fond cette
décision est incontestable il fallait
engager ce travail et quel que soit les
problématiques qu'on a constaté ou qu'on
va constater et qu'on évoquera sans
doute un peu plus tard
il faut absolument préserver cette
politique publique se volait là puisque
encore une fois l'enjeu est beaucoup
trop lourd derrière les conséquences
beaucoup trop lourdes je poursuis du
coup en étant 2023 comment les choses se
poursuivent bon on a les problématiques
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui mais il y a
des associations qu'on fait le job qui
l'ont fait en 2000 en 2020 qui l'ont
fait en 2021 2022 est-ce que aujourd'hui
il y a cette objective qui était le
vôtre je crois quand on lit la
documentation c'était de mettre des
structures un peu pérenne en place alors
dans le monde associatif pérennité est
toujours un sujet mais globalement en
tout cas c'était pas de faire one shot
si je puis dire mais d'essayer de de
poursuivre est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les choses
se poursuivent convenablement l'objectif
est de faire en sorte qu'effectivement
on puisse consolider tout ce qui relève
de ce volet d'action publique avec le
soutien fondamental de la société civile
donc faire en sorte que des projets se
pérennissent je vais prendre un exemple
une association qui n'a pas fait partie
formellement du fond Marianne qui
s'appelle Alma
et qui est un partenaire historique du
cpdr depuis des années à bénéficié de
subventions conséquentes avec des
niveaux extrêmement élevés avec derrière
des actions qui étaient tout à fait à la
hauteur du budget qui avait été alloué
cette association par exemple encore une
fois s'inscrit dans une action qui se
pérennise et c'est ce qu'on souhaite
envisager et c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
subventionné déjà depuis 2018 et qu'on a
continué à le subventionner jusqu'à
présent avec encore une fois des budgets
conséquents un projet important mais et
c'était d'ailleurs la seule association
qui s'inscrivait dans des actions contre
les cours sociétal sur ces questions de
défense de la République qui n'a pas été
formellement officiellement intégré au
fond Marianne mais toutes les
caractéristiques y étaient pourtant
évidemment réunis ça n'a pas été le cas
formellement puisque tout cela à savoir
la dernière subvention qui avait été
attribuée je parle de 2021 avait été
acté formellement à l'occasion du fameux
comité de programmation du 13 avril que
j'évoquais et puis ce que nous avions
acté avec le cabinet l'idée d'engager la
subvention qu'il s'agissait aussi de
prolonger cette action là que tout était
assez facile déjà mis en place tout
était déjà acté c'est la raison pour
laquelle il va rentrer mais on pourra
peut-être pas là après mais voilà donc
c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec
cette association là majeure mais qui
n'a pas été formellement inscrite dans
le cadre du fond Marianne en tout cas
l'objectif c'est typiquement ce type de
d'action de faire en sorte qu'elle soit
pérennisée bien évidemment les
associations les plus importantes qui
ont
participé au fond Marianne avait toute
demandé à évidemment s'inscrire dans une
si possible dans une démarche plus
réelle avec l'idée d'envisager des
actions qui subventionnées chaque année
ce qui paraît pas évidemment absurde on
en reparlera alors évidemment je
voudrais revenir maintenant venir sur le
comité de sélection des projets
alors vous avez
j'oserais dire préventivement traité un
bout du sujet en disant que
juridiquement c'était de la subvention
aux associations donc ça ne relevait pas
du même type de droit que l'on appelle
un projet traditionnel bon
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur ce point
d'abord sur le comité de sélection qui
peut paraître alors tout ça est lié bien
vous l'accordez à la question du temps
ça va vite ça fonce bon et ça d'une
certaine façon vous allez répondu vous
avez dit c'est pas mon c'est pas mon
tempo ou celui de votre organisme mais
c'est le tempo qu'on vous a donné que
vous pouvez comprendre mais qu'on vous a
donné donc vous inscrivez dans un temps
court et du coup on a un jury que j'ai
qualifié vous le savez d'un peu endogène
c'est-à-dire uniquement les membres du
site PDR et les membres du cabinet je
fais simple et donc ce jury endogène ne
fait pas appel à des compétences
extérieures
quand on voit certains résultats on
pourrait se dire c'est dommage que dans
ce jury par exemple il n'y ait pas eu un
peu plus un appel à des gens spécialisés
dans les questions des réseaux sociaux
des lampes extérieurs non pas sur le
contenu
des messages là je veux dire que c'est
difficile de faire
plus pointu que ceux qui s'en occupent
depuis des années mais sur la façon de
faire etc et on peut on regarde un peu
les résultats comme ça vu de très loin
on se dit quand même que faire passer à
des ados des messages sur des vidéos de
12 minutes ou de 10 minutes on s'est dit
qu'on ne doit pas avoir les mêmes jeunes
à la maison quoi parce que les miens au
bout de 30 secondes ils ont quitté le
truc voilà donc est-ce que finalement le
fait d'aller vite le fait de travailler
un peu de manière endogène vous
m'excusez ce mot mais bon est-ce que ça
vous a pas privé d'un peu de lucidité
extérieure sur comment on fait la cible
c'est ça comment on y va etc
il y a eu quel que soit la pression en
termes de temps
je tiens à le préciser clairement aucune
négligence tout a été fait malgré les
contraintes calendrier malgré notamment
cette période une surcharge de travail
de l'équipe je tiens je tiens à le dire
tout a été fait comme il se devait
concernant le comité de sélection
oui il s'agissait de trois membres du
cabinet et de trois membres du cpdr
autant je m'en souvienne la raison de ce
format était lié aussi
à l'idée travaillant sur une matière
comme très sensible de rester entre ceux
qui avaient vocation à connaître le
sujet
et je vais répondre très directement à
votre question monsieur le Président et
avec l'autorité politique chargée de
valider mais de contribuer aussi à des
échanges par définition avant de décider
formellement deloreats
je tiens à préciser avec toute
l'humilité qui doit nous caractériser
que il y avait néanmoins au sein du cpdr
des compétences en matière de
communication digitale la chargée de
mission qui avait un rôle de chef de
projet pendant plusieurs mois
connaissait très bien ces questions
aussi de contrediscours sociétal en
ligne
avait travaillé sur ces projets là
depuis ce type de projet depuis quelques
années
la responsable
de l'époque de du pôle métier concerné
était issu du privé avait été l'un des
cadres d'une société reconnue sur la
toile donc une connaissance des codes du
web clairement et
votre serviteur a été directeur du
Service d'information du gouvernement
pendant trois ans
avec une dimension digitale extrêmement
forte d'ailleurs qu'on avait fait
émerger qu'on avait développé
considérablement à l'époque où j'étais à
la tête de sa structure et j'ai été
aussi enseignant en sciences po sur des
questions de communication ou je vais
donc moi même travailler étudier fait
associer des experts sur ces sujets là
également à mes cours et à mes
réflexions pour vous dire que en tout
cas on n'est pas totalement déconnecté
de ces questions là au cpdr je peux
toujours se dire que on pourrait on peut
déjà on peut toujours faire mieux par
définition et c'est ce qu'on recherche à
faire
bien sûr que il aurait fallu avoir
peut-être d'autres services également et
peut-être des experts de cet ordre là en
tout cas au moment où ça se passe je
vous précise malgré tout
les quelques qualités compétences de des
membres du comité permettant quand même
de parler d'un sujet qu'il connaisse à
peu près
qui connaissent sincèrement qu'ils
connaissent on connaît le sujet de de la
communication numérique j'entends bien
mais après on parle on reparlera quand
on voit les résultats obtenus quoi où on
peut s'interroger bon voilà mais est-ce
que après coup vous regrettez pas quand
même l'idée que finalement ce comité de
sélection était composé
d'une équipe extrêmement proche et que
finalement il n'y a pas eu deuil
extérieur qui d'ailleurs aurait permis
par rapport à un certain nombre de
polémiques en cours peut-être d'apporter
vous voyez l'idée que il y a eu une
confrontation de point de vue dans peu
l'impression que malgré tout les six
personnes dont vous parlez bon travail
ensemble connaissent bien ce sujet là et
trouve leur accord sans doute alors vous
nous le direz assez facilement qu'un œil
extérieur technique ou pas aurait pu
apporter peut-être un peu de un peu de
questionnement à l'ensemble est-ce que
si vous aviez à refaire
tranquillement si vous aviez à refaire
ce type d'opération vous ouvririez pas
un petit peu le comité si j'avais à
nouveau à m'impliquer sur ce type
d'opération j'en tiré une première leçon
c'est de faire respecter une temporalité
qui permet de travailler dans des
conditions optimales et dans ces cas-là
on parle monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur on parle du comité sélection
mais on va venir dans quelques instants
dans le cadre du suivi ce qui a eu en
amont de la classe sélection locale du
suivi
incontestablement à contestablement le
fait d'avoir un peu plus de temps nous
aurez sans doute permis aussi d'associer
d'autres
directions
je l'évoquais je l'évoquais il y a
quelques minutes aussi ce pour comité
sélection je pense que
oui un peu plus de transversalité avec
d'autres acteurs par définition ne peut
qu'amplifier la réalité du travail
réalisé même si encore une fois je le
répète je considère que nous avons
accompli tout ce que nous devions
accomplir
avec les moyens qui étaient les nôtres
malgré la surcharge de travail mais en
étant extrêmement rigoureux surtout ce
qui devait faire surtout les process en
amont justement aval on y reviendra sans
aucun doute dans quelques minutes mais
voilà vous me demandez une leçon à tirer
c'est celle-ci avant tout et oui je
réponds à votre question aussi
concrètement sans doute associé mais les
deux sont liés je crois c'est que le
fait de pouvoir se poser
un minima et pouvoir donc dans ces
cas-là prendre le temps d'associer
d'autres personnes paraît sur ce sujet
comme sur bien d'autres et évidemment le
moyen d'optimiser ce type de projet
quelques questions toujours dans la dans
la foulée
diriez-vous que le le manque d'ouverture
de du comité de sélection et lié
exclusivement à des délais extrêmement
courts et contraint ou pas seulement et
à ce moment-là quel autre raison
moi je vois que le que le premier
élément je pense que si tout le monde
avait eu plus de temps de fait
en termes de méthodologie de process on
aurait pu prendre le temps également
d'élaborer cela par définition de
manière
un peu plus raisonnable entre guillemets
et faire en sorte que par définition
aussi on associe je le disais d'autres
acteurs du sein du ministère donc je
pense que tout est lié s'il y avait eu
plus de temps je pense que ici comme
dans le reste du processus il y aurait
aussi peut-être d'autres acteurs en
soutien en voilà et les choses se sont
faites oui rapidement très rapidement
donc je crois que c'était dans la
logique de trop rapide j'ai bien noté
vous avez évoqué un budget conséquent si
j'ai bien noté d'une association qui si
j'ai bien compris Alma depuis 2018 je me
dis que si vous dites budget conséquent
c'est que c'est important
[Musique]
et si deuxième question vous me posiez
monsieur le rapporteur
l'association n'apparaît pas
formellement dans le fond Marianne dans
la liste des lauréats c'est que encore
une fois à l'occasion du comité de
programmation précédent le comité de
sélection du fond Marianne il avait été
acté par le cabinet
le fait que après que nous ayons
instruit la demande de subvention de
cette association que nous connaissons
bien il avait été acté le fait que le
choix était validé et que nous allions
versé le montant d'une subvention et
équivalent à 500 000 euros donc ça avait
été acté et donc à partir du moment où
tout avait été acté il n'y avait plus de
sens faire en sorte qu'il dans ces cas
là participent au fond tout était décidé
avoir des actions supplémentaires ou
nouvelles qui n'était pas dans le
le programme que vous veniez de valider
ou vous étiez sur le point de valider
les actions proposées s'inscrivaient
dans le prolongement de ce qui avait été
proposé initialement et d'ailleurs des
actions de qualité objectivement
mais je sais que derrière à la demande
du cabinet c'est pour ça que Alma
apparaît dans certaines notes que vous
avez dû recevoir il avait été demandé de
l'intégrer mais mon interprétation c'est
que c'était l'idée de rendre cohérent un
bilan un suivi de l'ensemble des acteurs
associatifs travaillant dans le cadre du
contreco sociétal dans le cas de lutte
contre les séparatisme sachant que de
toute façon si
si quelqu'un avait voulu que l'Alma
apparaisse formellement il s'agissait
simplement de compléter ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure je vous
rappelle qu'on est passé de 2 millions
et demi à 2 millions 17000 honnêtement
ça n'aurait pas posé de problème ça
n'aurait pas fait vous voyez enfin en
venir justement je vais en lire tout de
suite finalement à la
compréhension du processus de sélection
des projets subventionnés puisqu'en fait
il y a pas de grignotation
et donc dans ce cas là quels sont les
critères objectifs sur lesquels vous
appuyez vous analyse puis vos choix
est-ce que des des certains des projets
transmis par des sessions et qui
finalement semble tenir en quelques mots
en quelques éléments très généraux
avez-vous dans ce cas demander des
éléments complémentaires
avant de prononcer de vous prononcer et
d'attribuer les subventions pour des
associations lorsqu'elles n'ont jamais
eu à travailler avec le ministère est-ce
que vous êtes dit banco quelle a été la
manière avec laquelle vous avez
éventuellement organisé des échanges
essayer de comprendre le fonctionnement
et sous quelle forme s'il y a eu des
échanges et ou des auditions
quelle forme ont-ils pris et
avez-vous
pu examiner tous les projets j'ai
entendu ce que vous avez dit sur le
nombre d'associations mais est-ce que
vous êtes allé dans le détail ou est-ce
que vous en avez écarté et à ce moment
là pour quelle raison
alors il y a eu un processus de
sélection qui s'est réparti en trois
étapes
tout d'abord après la formalisation de
l'appel à projet nous avons su 73
projets
d'associations
sur ces 73 il y en avait déjà une partie
conséquente qui ne répondait pas
exactement aux principaux critères
portés par l'appel à projet je vous
rappelle les deux axes premier axe
riposter
aux acteurs extrémistes séparatistes ou
complotistes deuxième axe l'idée de je
résume évidemment défendent promouvoir
les valeurs républicaines
il y avait également d'autres critères
excusez-moi une seconde
il n'y a pas un premier filtre avant
celui-là qu'on peut comprendre qui est
sur le fond
est-ce qu'il y a pas un premier filtre
administratif
traditionnellement
j'aurais dû préciser là c'est au niveau
administratif ce travail-là il est
produit par le cpdr ce que je suis en
train de vous dire le processus c'est à
dire qu'on reçoit les 73 dossiers et là
on a déjà un premier filtrage qui se
fait assez aisément puisque tout
simplement les principaux éléments
déterminants apparaissant dans le cahier
des charges de l'appel à projet ne sont
pas remplis donc je sais ce que je
disais soit le fait que ni l'un ni
l'autre des axes soit
clairement affichée avec du hors sujet
si j'ose dire ou alors tout simplement
aussi parce que des associations
pouvaient s'engager dans des projets à
caractère territorial il y avait l'idée
d'un rayonnement à l'échelle nationale
qui était demandé donc rien qu'avec ça
déjà on passe de 73 projets à 44 ça
c'est fait en interne ensuite deuxième
phase en interne toujours au sein du
cipdr
on va passer de 44 à 23 et là en interne
on rentre dans le fond des projets et là
on va essayer de déterminer la qualité
l'intelligence portée par tel ou tel
proposition la structuration du projet
on essaye évidemment de se renseigner
sur dans ces cas là ce qui a pu être
fait jusqu'à présent par tel ou tel
association il va de soi je l'évoquer
tout à l'heure que beaucoup de
désociations
qu'on postulées
connaissait déjà travailler déjà avec le
cpdr et réciproquement donc celle-ci par
définition quand encore une fois vous
avez un historique des partenariats de
confiance
une association reconnue d'utilité
publique
des experts reconnus dans tel ou tel
association cela suscite évidemment
par définition un préjugé positif tu
veux pas dire que il faut évidemment se
regarder étudier tout cela mais on avait
un certain nombre d'éléments qui
permettaient voilà permettre d'accélérer
le processus et d'aller jusqu'au bout
ensuite il a été il s'agissait à la fois
pour la chargée de mission qui s'est
consacrée à ce sujet là avec ce qu'il y
a eu aussi un travail ensuite collégiale
au sein de du pôle métier avant que
l'équipe me présente une proposition
des discussions des échanges et qui nous
amènent à une liste de 23 associations
qu'on va proposer
discussions dans le cadre du comité de
sélection avec le cabinet
voilà donc on arrive à 23
propositions et le comité sélection
comme vous le savez va décider que 17 de
ces associations peuvent bénéficier du
fond Marianne et vont devenir les
lauréats de ce de cette opération
alors je vais revenir sur vous venez
d'évoquer les raisons
qui peuvent être multiples des dossiers
qui ne répondent pas en totalité aux
critères voire des dossiers incomplets
pour autant
avez-vous
adressé
en tous les cas informés éventuellement
adressé des courriers à ces associations
leur disant un qui n'était pas retenue
éventuellement de pour quel motif
et où c'est des associations se
sont-elles adressées à vous pour avoir
des éléments complémentaires si rien
n'est fait
pour avoir des explications
complémentaires y a-t-il eu enfin des
réactions particulières de une ou
plusieurs d'entre elles
rien ne nous oblige comme vous le savez
juridiquement dans le cas du régime
juridique des subventions à entre
guillemets rendre des comptes aux
associations qui ne reçoivent pas qu'une
perçoivent pas des subventions
au-delà de ça elles ont reçu
l'information qu'elle n'était pas
retenue et
il y a eu quelques associations qui ont
demandé d'informations et je sais qu'il
y a eu des échanges avec la chargée de
mission souvent par téléphone
concernés pour expliquer le contexte en
rappelant pourquoi effectivement le
projet quel que soit la pertinence en
tout cas n'avait pas été spécifiquement
choisi dans le cadre du fond Marianne
voilà donc
je n'ai pas la liste des associations je
l'ai pas en tête je sais que il y avait
eu à ce moment-là ce que j'ai le
souvenir qu'elle m'en avait parlé il y a
eu peut-être deux trois associations qui
se sont manifestées pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi le projet n'avait
pas été
accepté je sais qu'il y avait eu dans
ces cas cet échange dans le cadre c'est
en fait des
j'ai envie de dire des échanges oraux
sans traces sans avoir concerné voilà
sans formalisme
je note
c'est une remarque en tous les cas à ce
stade vous évoquez qu'il faut que ce
soit fourni je dirais le projet de
l'association et je crois qu'on va avoir
l'occasion de voir que pour certains qui
ont pu être retenus qui ont d'ailleurs
été retenus c'était beaucoup plus
comment dirais-je succin puisque ça je
crois que la motivation obtenait en une
page je voulais toujours sur les la
question des l'absence de finalement de
tableau permettant d'évaluer de critères
de notation puisque vous n'y êtes pas
astreint par la procédure ce qui est
quand même étonnant c'est qu'on est vous
n'ayez aucun compte rendu
qui fasse la synthèse je dirais de ce
processus de sélection parce que
c'est pas pour le coup
votre administration n'est pas une
association manquante moyen en général
l'administration et vous l'avez dit dans
le propos intrusif certes vous avez Ebn
commande publique mais il y a un
formalisme qui s'impose donc qu'est-ce
qui explique que vous n'ayez pas à ce
stade et sur ce sujet
utiliser le même formalisme
alors deux éléments sur ce que vous
venez de dire monsieur rapporteur
tout d'abord considère qu'il y a eu des
notes précises je crois que vous avez
connaissance
permettant à échéance régulière de faire
un point
rédigé par la chef de projet concerné de
faire un point sur l'évolution
précisément de ce processus de sélection
jusqu'à au comité de sélection avec une
note
dater du 31 mai qui reprécise et qui
fait finalement office de compte-rendu
des avis portés par cette par ce comité
de sélection donc je me permets de
d'indiquer qu'il y a eu malgré tout un
suivi régulier
par par la collaboratrice concernée sur
l'ensemble du processus
de sélection jusqu'à la désignation des
lauréats à l'occasion du comité de
sélection où on voit bien l'évolution à
chaque fois des des projets la manière
dont en tout cas on peut se questionner
la question des montants qu'on peut être
évalués à la baisse pour certains à
l'occasion du comité de sélection c'est
j'entends ce que vous dites mais sur ces
comptes rendus
n'apparaissent pas ni les motifs pour
lesquels
les choix ont été ceux de du comité
alors
excusez-moi je pensais que vous me
parliez sur toute la temporalité est
concernée du processus
oui je sais que vous aviez fait cette
cette remarque
honnêtement je pense que là aussi je
pense qu'il faut anticiper et en tirer
les leçons sans ce que sur ce type de
réunion il faudrait à l'avenir
évidemment
qu'il y ait un compte rendu à minima
exhaustif pour mieux saisir la logique
casier à la décision concernant telle ou
telle association je vous confirme ça
n'a pas été le cas ça n'a pas été fait
ce que il est vrai que nous n'avons pas
l'habitude d'envisager ce type de
document extrêmement précis exhaustif à
l'occasion de réunion mais dans le cas
particulier de ce comité de sélection
étant donné l'enjeu je concède
pleinement que nous aurions dû
collectivement envisager un compte-rendu
avec également un certain nombre de
Verbatim en tout cas au moins saisir
saisir la logique qui permettait
d'expliquer pourquoi telle ou telle
association a été choisie ou telle autre
ne l'a pas été
je partage ce que vous venez de dire
et déplore effectivement puisque on est
bien là dans notre mission de suivi
d'évaluation de la dépense publique et
qu'elle soit en milliers en centaines de
milliers d'euros ou davantage je pense
que ce qu'attend de globalement nos
concitoyens c'est avoir une même rigueur
à la fois intellectuelle et je le redis
juridique administrative
je peux réagir à ce que vous venez de
dire je tiens à affirmer que nous nous
inscrivons dans la même philosophie que
celle que vous venez d'annoncer au-delà
de la philosophie que je crois que nous
partageons
[Musique]
le même sens de la responsabilité et je
peux vous garantir que même si nous
disposons pas d'un compte-rendu
exhaustif au sens où vous l'indiquiez de
ce comité de sélection toute la rigueur
a été mise en place
pour justement faire en sorte que en
fonction des discussions des échanges
que vous avez pu avoir sur tel ou tel
projet tel ou telle association
les choix ont été faits ont été mesurés
et pesées et je vais revenir je pense
dans quelques minutes sur certains
dossiers que vous voulez
étudier puisque j'ai compris avant de
venir vous voir il y a quelques jours
que vous n'avez pas reçu quelques pièces
et notamment les fiches d'instruction
exhaustives de certains projets donc
c'est une
erreur
que vous nous avez envoyé voilà c'est
bien pour ça que je vous dis c'est une
erreur de notre part nous aurions dû
vous envoyer cette pièce je pense
notamment à l'uspm qu'on va sans doute
évoquer dans quelques instants et il n'y
avait pas je vous rassure d'emblée
qu'une fiche d'une petite page nous
avons su une fiche d'instruction en
bonnet due forme de plusieurs pages qui
étaient très détaillées et qui
permettait évidemment d'étayer et de ce
qui a été notre cas de nous convaincre
d'envisager de lui accorder la première
subvention mais j'ai retrouvé dans
quelques minutes mais c'est dommage
monsieur secrétaire général de le
découvrir en séance je vous le confirme
et je ne peux que le regretter et donc
et m'en excuser je dirais vous avez
heureusement vous êtes venus et qu'on
vous a invité
évidemment mais de toute façon
ou alors on dirait c'est la poste non
pas du tout loin de nous l'idée de je
vienne pas d'essayer d'esquiver nos
responsabilités je viens de vous dire
que c'est notre faute et je l'endosse
totalement si jamais nous n'avions pas
eu cet échange vous l'aurez reçu
peut-être pas par la poste mais par
internet ou par clé USB
évidemment merci je rappelle à nos
collègues que dans quelques minutes
encore d'échange et puis nos collègues
pourront prendre la parole je voudrais
il se trouve que dans les documents
alors vous les documents importants donc
ne sont pas arrivés malheureusement
c'est important parce que certains
mais celui-là est important quand même
parce que ça effectivement si on
considère que c'est ce qui est écrit sur
une page simple un peu je dirais pas
griffonné mais rapidement écrit etc bon
et des choses très générales ça surprend
mais on y reviendra tout à l'heure par
contre il y a vous nous avez envoyé un
seul document finalement un peu relatif
relatif aux explications et elle
concerne vous le savez puisque vous
l'avez envoyé l'association coexister et
vous marquez enfin vous embarquez dans
le dans le commentaire c'est le seul que
nous ayons
association dont le positionnement est
explicitement en opposition avec la
ligne gouvernementale
c'est la seule association dont on voit
pourquoi elle a été refusée
sur un argument en opposition à la ligne
gouvernementale
où il peut y avoir plusieurs lectures on
va le dire comme ça est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner votre lecture
la rédaction
telle que vous l'avez
énoncé évidemment peut
susciter un certain nombre de lectures
différentes il va de soi qu'il s'agit
d'une posture de cette association
qui n'est pas conforme à la ligne
gouvernementale concernant la question
majeure de laïcité
avec une divergence totale
c'est tout à fait le droit par
définition de cette association comme
bien d'autres de penser de dire de faire
ce qu'elle veut ou presque condition
qu'elle respecte l'ordre public mais le
projet porté par cette association là ne
correspond en aucun cas à la ligne
portée par l'exécutif sur cette question
de laïcité avec une approche
qui
est
parfois en lien avec des acteurs que
nous ne considérons pas comme des
défenseurs
de la République
parfois même comme des personnes ayant
vocation à essayer de l'affaiblir avec
une approche
qui n'est pas celle encore une fois
s'inscrivant dans le l'attachement qui
est le nôtre au pacte républicain à
l'histoire qui est la nôtre à notre à
nos lois et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette association a été écartée
à l'occasion de ce processus de
sélection
puisque pendant peut-être pour aller
jusqu'au bout puisque ce sera aussi sans
doute un autre sujet abordé un peu plus
tard il y a pas d'ambiguïté possible
avec l'idée d'une opposition à une
gouvernementale puisque il n'y a pas à
ma connaissance de propos à caractère
politique porté par cette association là
en tout cas ça m'est jamais remonté
donc c'est bien la preuve qu'on est on
parle simplement de la conception qu'on
se fait de la laïcité et l'idée de ne
pas s'engager dans une démarche qui vise
à promouvoir
l'idée
justement de ne pas essayer de coexister
les uns aux côtés des autres mais de
veiller à s'intégrer dans
le cadre républicain faisant en sorte
que l'égalité la fraternité la liberté
soit pleinement prégnante et qu'on
puisse sortir d'une logique qui parfois
est proche de vision
caractériser comme étant
proche de de la des colonialisme parfois
proche de ce qu'on appelle les aussi le
mouvement des Indigènes de la République
qui n'est pas toujours très clair ou
plutôt plus précisément qui est trop
clair sur encore une fois la ligne
politique au sens neutre du terme porter
par par l'État pourquoi vous n'avez pas
dès lors mis dans le cahier des charges
quasiment
un peu la notion de laïcité que vous
entendiez porter et que vous entendiez
que les porteurs de projets sur laquelle
les porteurs de projets devraient
s'aligner d'une certaine façon
on sait tous je crois ici de cette
assemblée les débats
longs rude qui ont pu avoir lieu dans
les années passées sur la notion de
laïcité elle-même
laïcité considérée quelquefois comme
vision laïque un peu trop molle ou trop
ouverte vision plus plus dur plus raide
peut-être on fait c'est une je vous
laisse le choix des mots
ou plus se conforme selon l'idée
on connaît on a tous en tête c'est ce
niveau de discussion intellectuelle
est-ce que d'une certaine façon vous
pensez pas que cette discussion
intellectuelle elle a aussi sa place
dans le débat autrement dit
lorsque l'on veut faire un contre
discours républicain et que l'on veut
préparer les esprits à avoir leur propre
opinion sur les sujets ce qu'il faut pas
un peu d'après vous laisser coexister un
peu de débat sur le sujet laïque par
lui-même
où faut-il bon dire ben non c'est un peu
votre réponse je l'extrapole peut-être
un peu mais non il y a une ligne
gouvernementale au sein de la laïcité
d'accord sur le sujet laïque et on s'en
tient à cela mais est-ce que vous pensez
pas que c'est un peu contre-productif et
que finalement la question laïque c'est
une question ouverte aujourd'hui bon
dans certaines limites on est on est
bien d'accord
mais je parle pas du discours
indigéniste etc je parle bien au sein de
ceux qui défendent la notion de laïcité
il y a bien une variété de débats j'ai
même lu d'ailleurs qu'un intellectuel
disait autant de laïques autant de
autant de vision laïque quoi je fais
simple quasiment autant de citoyens
autant de vision de la laïcité voilà
est-ce que vous avez pas d'une certaine
façon peut-être un volontairement mais
vous allez nous le dire un peu contenu
ce débat je soyez certain que je ne
crois pas être le seul à apporter cette
approche là
nous sommes évidemment partisans du
pluralisme
qui est l'un des fondements et l'un des
joyaux de la démocratie française c'est
pas la c'est pas cette question là
l'idée c'est de veiller à ce que un
certain nombre d'acteurs associatifs qui
sont encore une fois totalement libres
de s'exprimer comme ils le souhaitent
de ne pas
contribuer à les accompagner
financièrement à travers des fonds
publics dans le cadre de d'action de
prise de parole que nous on peut
considérer tout ça discutable mais comme
parfois assez ambigu vis-à-vis certains
acteurs
et que ces acteurs ne sont peut-être pas
les principaux défenseurs de la
République je propose de pas en dire
plus et je suis tout à fait ouvert à la
discussion dans ce cadre là comme dans
un autre mais l'idée c'est d'être
cohérent tout simplement par rapport à
une vision qui n'est pas étriquée qui ne
joue pas n'a pas besoin d'être
qualifié mais d'une vision qui est tout
simplement conforme à la laïcité à
l'esprit de la loi et de ce que nous
envisageons de porter collectivement je
crois depuis maintenant plusieurs
plusieurs décennies nous n'irons pas
plus loin sur le débat qui nous
entraînerait très loin mais c'était
plutôt pour voir sur les critères
d'attribution les choix etc à partir de
la seule remarque que l'on avait
concernant une association justement
peut-être pour clore définitivement ce
sujet là c'est bien parce que je reviens
sur ce que j'évoquais il y a quelques
instants nous sommes évidemment ouverts
et partisan du pluralisme qu'il n'y
avait pas une définition
alors
promouvoir la défense de la républicaine
à condition que non justement l'idée
c'était de garder cet état d'esprit qui
d'ailleurs est caractérise l'appel à
projet c'est vraiment l'idée encore une
fois de faire émerger de nouveaux
acteurs de faire en sorte que
des nouvelles méthodes de travail des
innovations puissent émerger à
l'occasion de ce cadre-là contrairement
à la commande publique qui elle précise
comme vous le savez pertinemment le
cadre très exact très précis l'idée
c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout la logique
d'un appel à projet et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que ce format là
était pertinent permettant justement
d'ouvrir finalement tous les possibles
le chant de tous les possibles la seule
limite que on a fixé collectivement
c'était l'idée de s'inscrire dans la
conception que nous nous faisons de la
République et sa défense sans avoir une
définition extrêmement clair précise on
peut le faire mais c'était pas
l'objectif donc l'idée justement et je
peux vous garantir allons jusqu'au bout
et peut-être faire là-dessus je pense
que si vous
un débat ou finalement bon c'est assez
naturel quoi il y a eu des discussions
bien sûr on est passé de 23 à 17 donc
c'est bien bien la preuve que et je vous
rappelle que nous avons supprimé 20% du
budget qui était prévu initialement donc
c'est bien la preuve d'une part au
passage contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre qu'il y avait pas la volonté de
distribuer à plein d'amis puisqu'il y
avait il y avait il y avait encore de la
marge si certains voulaient abuser de
cela c'est aussi absurde mais c'est pour
ça je préfère le dire avec ironie et
puis derrière
les dossiers proposés on aurait pu étant
donné le nombre de dossiers qui avaient
été posés sur la table on aurait pu
envisager qu'un ait plus et donc c'est
dans le cas de ces échanges
que il a été décidé collectivement de
limiter à 17 donc il y a bien eu
discussion
il y a eu des approches différentes il y
a pas eu de confrontation il y a pas eu
de de divergence frontale mais il y a eu
il y a eu des échanges il y a eu des
désaccords il y a la fin on trouve un
accord voilà sur certains sujets très
bien sûr
sur les associations alors vous avez
déjà un peu répondu mais
les deux grosses associations en dehors
des deux on parlera à la fin qui ont
suscité quelques interventions
particulières Civic Fab et fraternité
générale elles étaient donc déjà
financées par le père PDF pardon avant
l'appel à projet est-ce que la
subvention du format Marianne a été
l'occasion de leur demander de faire
plus ou est-ce que finalement c'était on
revient à cette question est-ce que
c'était revenir à leur redonner ce
qu'elles avaient peut-être en donnant un
peu plus pour leur permettre de
développer leurs actions mais sans leur
demander d'action supplémentaire comment
vous jugez ça
prenons l'exemple de Civic Fab qui est
un acteur majeur qui
à chaque fois a travaillé avec
consciencieusement des professionnels et
et a vraiment
répondu à toutes nos attentes
il y a eu l'idée évidemment de monter
en exigence avec dans le prolongement de
ce qui était fait mais de donner plus
d'ampleur de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
de nouveaux formats proposés de
nouvelles vidéos par exemple typiquement
en lien évident avec le l'appel à projet
fond Marianne des vidéos spécifiquement
consacrées à la prévention de la
radicalisation puisque il s'agissait de
parler du djihadisme de l'islamisme de
l'islam radical ça ça n'avait pas été
fait et
d'ailleurs je salue leur courage parce
que le fait de s'attaquer à ces
questions là on le sait peut avoir des
conséquences lourdes
quelques experts qu'on connaît
se retrouvent sous protection policière
tout simplement pour oser aborder ces
sujets avec lucidité avec objectifs et
on est quand même en France en 2023 je
voilà on trouve pas ça ailleurs donc ils
ont eu ce courage là et l'idée c'était
de donner beaucoup plus de force encore
à des formats qui existaient et ils ont
démultiplié donc il y a eu une montée en
puissance par rapport à ce qui pouvait
être fait jusqu'à présent donc rien que
par rapport à cela pour le coup je pense
que c'est la preuve que il peut y avoir
des un atout à ce que ce projet puisse
être monté et que ce type d'association
puisse y répondre comme ils l'ont fait
avec intelligence
on revient un petit peu rapidement et
puis après on reviendra sur deux cas
spécifiques sur le comment dire comment
on est passé entre l'exécution de fond
Marianne est-ce que sur l'exécution de
fond Marianne est-ce que finalement vous
avez des procédures identiques à toutes
les subventions du fi PDF est-ce que
c'est la même chose est-ce que vous avez
un traitement différent
est-ce que vous avez
opéré des contrôles parce que mais on y
reviendra sur les cas spécifiques ça
plus spécifique permettra d'éclairer le
sujet c'est de voir comment on passe
effectivement de quelques lignes à un
projet réel de 300.000 euros par exemple
ça passe par un nombre de vidéos un
nombre d'actions un truc que sais-je
donc on en reparlera peut-être tout à
l'heure mais déjà est-ce que globalement
vous avez calqué si je puis dire le mode
de contrôle du fond au mode contrôle
tout à fait il s'agit du régime
juridique de subventions à travers
l'appel à projet avec des procédures euh
qui ont été mis en place conformément à
ce que l'on fait dans le cas du suivi
des subventions de ce type là dans le
cas spécifique du fond Marianne une
procédure spécifique a été élaborée en
lien entre le pôle métier et le pôle
administratif et financier sous la
houlette de mon adjoint que vous aurez
le plaisir d'entendre dans quelques
minutes
en mettant en place des référents en
mettant en place des process en mettant
en place également une un circuit
informatique permettant de trouver très
facilement que quel que soit le pôle tel
ou tel élément du dossier pour pouvoir
veillez à ce que le suivi soit opéré de
manière convenable et puis envisager un
certain nombre de de contrôle
je rappelle que dans le cadre de
cette procédure-là s'inscrivant je le
rappelle dans le cadre du FIPD
typiquement là on a à chaque fois
demander comme on le fait régulièrement
dans le cas de subventions publiques
à l'issue des actions un CeRFI un compte
rendu financier bien sûr dans les six
mois suivant la fin de de l'exercice les
comptes annuels ou les états financiers
approuvés dans le cas où comme vous le
savez une structure reçoit un montant
supérieur à 153000 euros le rapport du
commissaire aux comptes et puis le
rapport d'activité annuelle et à chaque
fois ces éléments là ont été demandés et
quand on a eu on a été confronté à
certains problèmes et bien ces cas là on
a pris les décisions qu'il fallait
prendre qu'il s'agisse de fond Marianne
il s'agisse de manière générale des
subventions
portées par par le cipdr merci on va
ouvrir peut-être quelques questions s'il
y en a
donné peut-être
la parole donc à Madame un autre
rapporteur spécial
de la mission administration générale et
territoriale de l'État Isabelle briquet
pouvoir commencer et je prends les
questions s'il y en a merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Secrétaire général
une demande de précision si vous voulez
bien parce que ça c'est un sujet qui a
déjà été évoqué par le président donc
les crédits attribués au titre du fond
Marianne visant en partie un des
associations qui étaient déjà financées
au titre du programme radicalisation du
fond interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
donc quelle mesure les crédits dédiés au
fond Marianne ont-ils résulté de
redéploiement interne au FIPD ou bien
ont-ils correspondu à des crédits
nouveaux parce que j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait les dépenses nouvelles
c'était pas forcément
il y avait pas forcément de dépenses
nouvelles donc votre réponse donc j'ai
peut-être mal interprété donc j'aimerais
bien avoir la précision à ce sujet là et
à quel montant estimez-vous la reprise
du par le fond Marianne de subventions
déjà existantes sur le fupd plus
précisément
quel montant devons-nous retrancher au 2
millions du fond Marianne si on tient
compte des subventions qui auraient été
versées
sans sans se font
merci Madame c'est la triste pour cette
question
il ne s'agissait pas de
fonds complémentaires il s'agissait de
rester sur l'enveloppe qui était dédié
du programme r du FIPD avec tout
simplement un fléchage sur ces actions
là donc il y a pas eu d'abondement du
FIPD spécifiquement pour alimenter ce
projet lié au fond Marianne voilà
sur votre deuxième question j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion de vous transmettre
précisément les les éléments dans la
foulée si vous le voulez bien je
voudrais préciser ça le calculer avec
l'équipe et puis vous transmettre ça
soit avant la fin de l'audition soit
dans la foulée si vous voulez bien par
mail donc pour vous donner des éléments
très précis voilà mais je pense que la
question essentielle c'était ce que vous
venez d'évoquer en tout cas je vous ai
répondu il y a pas eu d'abondement
supplémentaire pour alimenter
cet appel à projet
bien je vois pas pour l'instant d'autres
questions donc nous en poursuivre oui je
voulais d'abord peut-être avant la
dernière question revenir quand même
vous avez expliqué que que vous aviez
manqué
comment dirais-je de rigueur en tous les
cas dans le la sélection moi je continue
d'avoir une question je ne sais toujours
pas comment quelles ont été les critères
qui ont permis d'effectuer la sélection
et ce qui est aussi important comment
vous avez choisi de
d'attribuer des sommes de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros à
certaines associations et pas d'autres
pourquoi comment pour l'instant les
éléments que vous que vous communiquez
ne me donne aucune réponse d'accord je
vais tâcher d'y répondre monsieur
rapporteur déjà en précisant en
rappelant que dans le cadre du régime
juridique des subventions et de l'esprit
de cet appel à projet des appels à
projets de manière générale l'idée c'est
précisément de pouvoir faire émerger
encore une fois des acteurs particuliers
avec des projets qui peuvent être
totalement différents
juste pour faire comprendre que
il n'y a pas de possibilité dans ces cas
là encore une fois d'une grille
d'analyse comme on le retrouve avec un
marché public
en demandant de remplir tel ou tel case
il s'agit vraiment de prendre en
considération
précisément dans la volonté de faire
émerger des acteurs innovants des
projets qui peuvent être totalement
divers donc par définition vous dites
des acteurs innovants je dis pas la même
chose des acteurs qui peuvent être
nouveaux qui peuvent être innovants mais
qui peuvent être aussi des acteurs que
vous connaissez bien ce que vous nous en
avez évoqué un certain nombre je reviens
aussi sur Alma où nous avait dit on les
a finalement
je dirais la validation de leur
programme était effectué enfin voilà moi
je je fais bien attention aux éléments
que vous nous donnez pardon j'entends
bien et je vous en remercie je j'en
prends bien note vous avez raison
l'acteur innovant et des acteurs que
l'on connaît déjà qui peuvent faire
preuve d'innovation dans ce sens là que
je le que je l'évoquais donc la nature
même de cette opération
ne contribue pas à
la simplicité sur le fait de pouvoir
envisager une grille d'analyse commune
premièrement ensuite sur les montants
les montants
qui ont été attribués correspondent à la
base à la nature des projets proposés
nous avons
validé un certain nombre de projets avec
des budgets conséquents que l'on
considérait comme étant suffisamment
solide et d'autres projets
faisaient des demandes de subvention
avec des montants considérablement plus
faibles nous n'allions pas nous-mêmes
proposer d'augmenter ou de proposer une
enveloppe supplémentaire donc on a
accepté les projets un certain nombre de
projets à très haut niveau budgétaire
considérant que la nature du projet la
construction de ces projets permettait
de laisser croire que en fonction des
informations qui nous remontées en
fonction encore une fois de la stratégie
qui était déployée de la connaissance
des sujets nous étions en mesure de
pouvoir attribuer ces subventions
d'accord donc en gros
[Musique]
c'est le propre du régime des
subventions finalement une une
appréciation
qui réservée au comité et
un certain pouvoir discrétionnel
conduit et construire en vous entendre
en toute objectivité mais voilà on s'en
tient là quel que soit finalement
ses propres dispositifs c'est en fait
votre réponse monsieur rapporteur je
pense que vous savez mieux que moi que
précisément ce pourra discrétionnaire il
est totalement lié encore une fois au
régime juridique des subventions donc
c'est pas une c'était pas une forme de
de cas particulier c'est comme ça que ça
se passe à partir du moment où on engage
ce processus là à travers des
subventions sur un appel à projet qui
quand même
qui a été lancé avec comment dirais-je
à certaines éclat et voilà qui qui fait
suite comme l'a dit tout à l'heure le
président un événement particulièrement
odieux moi j'ai une dernière question
sur
cette première partie
à la suite du
des élections présidentielles parce que
j'ai bien noté qu'on avait quand même
dans les équipes à partir de la fin du
mois de décembre il y a un peu une des
changements une évaporation de de
membres de dans le cabinet et que les
choses ont l'air de reprendre plutôt à
la fin de l'été donc le nomination d'une
nouvelle secrétaire des tâches chargée
de la citoyenneté madame bacs donc en
juillet 2022
qu'elle a été quelles ont été les
éléments de de connaissance du
dispositif de transmission d'information
une ou plusieurs réunions sur la
question du fond Marianne ont-elles été
organisée ou est-ce que ça faisait
partie du paquet cadeau de on transmet
et
la nouvelle ministre fait de ce dossier
laisse la continuité républicaine le
laissant sommeil que globalement
qu'est-ce qui commence se sont passés
les choses c'est un dossier qui date il
y a deux ans donc je n'avais pas eu
l'occasion d'en parler
au moment de l'arrivée puis
l'installation la ministre et de son
cabinet et c'est lorsque
[Musique]
un certain nombre de médias ont commencé
à s'intéresser au sujet que évidemment
le cabinet m'a demandé de faire un point
très précis et évidemment m'a demandé de
faire un point et donc c'est ce que j'ai
fait en relatant tout le processus
l'historique et
puis vous connaissez la suite sur
l'ensemble des actions je vais être mené
concrètement puisque derrière il y a eu
on va l'aborder avec l'une des grandes
associations un certain nombre de
démarches qui ont été engagés par ces
PDR je pense à l'ucpm avec Le refus de
versement d'une d'un deuxième tranche un
contrôle de 2e niveau qui a été lancé
qui est encore en cours au moment où on
se parle puisque ce sont des centaines
de pièces qui sont étudiées par le
contrôleur interne financier que nous
n'avons pas eu pendant ce poste là
pendant plusieurs mois et notamment
pendant la première phase du fond
Marianne et par rapport à un article 40
qui a été engagé
qui a été engagée à l'attention de la
procure de la République comme vous le
savez concernant l'association et
concernant l'autre association
problématique
reconstruire le commun
vous savez aussi c'est la secrétaire
d'État
je dois vous dire que je manque pas de
m'interroger sur ce que vous venez de
dire
on a un dossier qui est quand même un
peu comme un étendard que je le redis
regarde un événement dramatique un fond
Marianne
une élection présidentielle une nouvelle
ministre et en fait j'ai envie de dire
c'est quasiment post restant il ne se
passe rien vous venez de le dire jusqu'à
ce que les comment dirais-je les médias
face surgir dans l'actualité des
questions autour du format
je trouve ça me paraît
ça me pose question là encore au regard
de l'organisation ne serait-ce que de ce
qui m'intéresse aussi de
l'administration puisque nous sommes là
pour suivre le contrôle de la bonne
utilisation des fonds et je vous le
disais en ayant reconstitué un peu la
chronologie de ce fond je vois bien que
à partir du 31 décembre en gros jusqu'au
mois de septembre 21 jusqu'au mois de
septembre 22 il ne se passe plus rien
comme si le temps d'une élection le je
dirais le temps était suspendu
voilà ça me pose question et je trouve
ça assez surprenant je je
réponds à votre interpellation monsieur
le rapporteur
bien sûr que le sujet faisait partie
avait été brièvement abordé dans le
cadre de l'ensemble des actions qui
avait été menées dans le cadre du
quinquennat précédent mais il n'y avait
aucune raison au moment où la nouvelle
administra arrive et son équipe
d'évoquer le sujet puisque nous n'avions
pas connaissance de problèmes à ce
moment-là cette après dans notamment les
derniers mois
je vous parle là à partir de maintenant
dans le cas
je vous coupe juste une seconde
la question n'est pas
techniquement on comprend ce que vous
comprend bien ce que vous nous dites
d'une certaine façon je suis pas sûr de
cœur que la question s'adresse à vous on
verra par la suite notre personne à
écouter entendre mais sincèrement d'un
côté on a ce qu'il faut bien voir
connaissez très bien ce milieu vous
savez que les actions
du fi-pdr globalement je parle du fond
globalement elles n'ont pas communica
peu on va dire ça comme ça il y a
beaucoup d'actions très utiles par
exemple sur la formation des préfets de
la formation dans le monde enseignant
enfin il y a beaucoup d'actions de
formation sur ces questions qui sont
menées mais de manière j'allais dire
extrêmement discrète la différence vous
l'avez d'ailleurs dit par votre mot
d'introduction c'est qu'on a on parle du
fort Marianne comme une quantité
particulière par rapport à un événement
politique gravissime je dis politique
par ces répercussions grave ici et donc
la question je crois que pose le
rapporteur c'est de dire quand la
ministre arrive finalement c'est traité
comme un dossier comme les autres quoi
ce que je veux dire et c'est ce que vous
nous dites c'est un dossier parmi les
autres comme il n'y avait pas de sujet
particulier ça fait l'objet
c'est dans une liste de dossiers mais il
y a pas d'attention particulière je
rappelle qu'à l'époque où ça a été lancé
pourquoi le nombre d'interventions
médias de la ministre à l'époque ça a
été quelque chose de tout à fait
considérable et ça frappe ça a marché
excusez-moi de le dire comme ça c'est à
dire il y a des campagnes de
communication qui débouchent sur rien
mais ça a donné à penser que le
gouvernement se saisissait plus que hier
puisqu'on mettait une appellation
particulière
de cette question et donc
nouveau ministre moi je suis nouveau
ministre pas mon truc pour pas j'ai rien
là-dessus je suis nouveau ministre je
prends les dossiers je regarde quels
sont les dossiers comme peu de
sensibilité politique je parle pas
d'importance majeures par rapport à
l'ensemble des dispositifs que vous
pilotez mais il y a une sensibilité
particulière ce que vous nous dites on
va pas aller plus loin puisque c'est pas
à vous finalement c'est que bon jusqu'au
moment où la presse se saisit de
question le sujet n'existe pas dans le
cabinet on va faire simple pas mettre en
cause la ministre par elle-même quoi
mais cabinet vient pas vers vous en
disant il y a une super opération il
faut la développer il faut renforcer
j'en sais rien donc c'est plutôt calme
plat calme plat voilà je vous demande je
vous impose pas de me répondre
parce que je veux pas qu'il y ait de
malentendu dessus encore une fois le
sujet est abordé à l'occasion de
l'installation de la nouvelle équipe
bien évidemment je l'ai dit on a abordé
le sujet
il n'y a pas de réunion Haddock sur ce
sujet là il n'y a pas de note spécifique
sur ce sujet là quel que soit son
importance au moment il est engagé
pardonnez-moi mais je suis bien placé
pour savoir ce qui s'est passé il y a
deux ans je suis arrivé je suis arrivé
mais alors quelques quelques jours
quelques jours
donc
évidemment comme vous je pense avoir
trop conscience de la gravité et de la
responsabilité qui nous incombe par
rapport à ce sujet là donc il y a aucune
légèreté par rapport à ce sujet il y a
strictement aucune légèreté aucune
maintenant au moment 2 ans plus tard où
la nouvelle équipe s'installe j'évoque
le sujet bien sûr mais je vous précise
que au moment où l'équipe s'installe et
pendant plusieurs mois il n'y a pas de
problème qui remonte à la surface et
nous sommes nous-mêmes en train
d'engager le processus de contrôle en
interne les équipes et ça pour le coup
on n'a pas attendu qui est l'emballement
médiatique pour le faire il y a déjà un
processus de contrôle qui est engagé
dans le cas des six mois après la fin de
l'action notamment je pense à l'ucpm
et puisque nous sommes confrontés à des
problèmes on va y venir
voilà nous nous réagissons comme il se
doit mais jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait ces
problèmes avec ou sans média au passage
de toute façon il y avait pas de raison
de revenir en détail dessus puisque bien
sûr que ça avait été on avait évoqué le
sujet j'avais présenté ce qui avait été
fait par l'équipe mais ça y est ce sujet
n'avait pas vocation est reproduit deux
ans plus tard ou trois ans plus tard
en tout cas ça n'a pas été évoqué
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle il
y avait pas de réunion Haddock
spécifique sur le sujet étant donné que
jusqu'à ces deux derniers mois trois
derniers mois parce que avant que les
médias sont parts du sujet on avait déjà
remarqué que là du côté de l'ucpm il y
avait des difficultés récurrentes à
obtenir enfin
pour vous dire que ce sujet là voilà on
en a parlé mais sous cet angle là à
partir du moment où les problèmes sont
apparus mais après j'ai compris ce que
vous avez dit sur la dimension politique
l'administration en tout cas je vous
explique factuellement ce qui s'est
passé très bien c'est très clair merci
on en vient donc au premier des deux
sujets
qui ont fait l'objet en tout cas de de
commentaires de questionnements
notamment dans la presse qui m'a
d'ailleurs amené à vous demander un
certain nombre d'explication pour
comment dire d'une certaine façon
dire les choses c'est même le sens de
cette commission dire les choses et
après à partir de choses factuelles
chacun fera son opinion bien sûr
alors allons sur cette association et
allons-y de manière un peu un peu
générale d'abord alors d'abord comment
expliquer vous le choix d'accorder à
cette association la principale
subvention du fond Marianne alors ça je
vois un peu et je parle là du montant de
la convention puisque en réalité
l'association n'a pas eu 40% qui qui
n'ont pas été donnés vous allez y
revenir donc au titre d'un lutte du
titre du volet lutte contre la
radicalisation alors que les statues de
l'association bien sûr alors ils sont de
1920 bon on peut comprendre que enfin
ils ont pas été du tout nettoyer
actualiser et en tout cas ça fait
référence à tout ce qu'on veut sauf à ce
type de sujet
alors la première question c'est ça donc
d'où ça vient
d'où ça sort je parle pas ici par le pas
des questions est-ce que vous
connaissiez etc vous l'avez dit on y
revient pas c'est un petit monde dans
laquelle les gens se connaissent on va
pas vous le faire répéter à l'infini
donc la question c'est d'où vient ce
projet est-ce qu'il vient par vous
est-ce qu'il vient par le cabinet
par où il arrive ce projet qui fait que
une association qui n'a rien à voir avec
le sujet a priori dans ces actions
qu'elle mènent tout d'un coup peut
prétendre à une subvention fond Marianne
alors que jusqu'à présent elle était
inconnue si je puis dire en tant que
fond d'intervention que vous pilotez
tout d'abord préciser que il n'y a
quasiment pas voir aucune association
qui dans ses statues
évoque la question de la lutte contre le
séparatisme ou explicitement Rif je
pense que vraiment
on est toujours plutôt sur la question
de la rigueur du Pré au loin
du travail sur l'esprit critique de la
promotion des valeurs mais voilà sur ce
sujet spécifique il y a de la lutte
contre le séparatisme oui en levant la
notion du statut je vous ai dit
que vous nous disiez l'inverse il y a
jamais eu de dossier de cette
association
d'une manière générale les associations
n'aborent pas le sujet
aussi explicitement
il faut avoir en tête que
[Musique]
moi j'ai appris que
la priori cette association allait
pouvoir bénéficier du fond Marianne
après un appel téléphonique que je
reçois de monsieur cifaoui qui me dit
sortir d'un rendez-vous de la ministre
qui lui parle du fond Marianne
et
donc ils en comprendre que il avait
toute sa place étant donné son statut
étant donné son implication son
investissement
donc je comprends qu'il y a eu des
échanges à ce niveau là
ensuite il faut avoir en tête des
éléments aussi objectifs concernant
l'association
évidemment
relativisant la nature des statues
datant de cette époque
j'ai quand même noté que cette
association elle était impliquée dans la
question de la jeunesse
d'une forme de citoyenneté d'engagement
lié à la jeunesse relevant des codes de
cette période là mais ça me paraît pas
totalement incongru ensuite surtout
il s'agit ce qui arrive comme vous le
savez
peu fréquemment d'une association
reconnue d'utilité publique quand même
vous donne un statut qui vous savez
encore une fois mieux que moi à test
d'un sérieux atteste de finance qui sont
censés être saine et d'un rayonnement
d'actions à l'échelle nationale
cette association en 2016
à travers ses chargées de mission
prévention à travailler sur les
questions de radicalisation
puisque
Rafel Saint-Vincent qui est l'un des
responsables à l'époque l'un des
référents prévention de la
radicalisation de cette association là
ne sollicite quand je suis moi directeur
du SIG
et vient me présenter son livre menace
sous la vivre sur la menace terroriste
avec cette idée qui était intéressante
justement de à l'époque de réfléchir à
cette question d'une culture de sécurité
un caractère préventif mais dans le
cadre du choc terroriste que nous avions
subis en 2015
et
lui-même même si se présente pas comme
étant responsable l'un des responsables
de l'US et seppm d'ailleurs je ne
retiens pas que c'est cette association
là à l'époque il me présente son livre
mais je comprends que apost Iuri qu'il y
a une sensibilité aussi au sein de cette
association là sur ces sujets preuve en
est avec l'écriture la diffusion de cet
ouvrage et d'ailleurs qui avait aussi
été le fruit d'une collaboration avec la
fVT l'Association française des victimes
du terrorisme puisque je crois de
mémoire que l'ensemble des des
sommes rassemblées par la vente de ce
livre était censé être fléchés ensuite
vers life VT donc un lien concret sur
les questions terrorisme radicalisation
victime de terrorisme
et puis il y a par rapport à ce projet
au moment où il est présenté je reviens
objectivement la présence de Monsieur
cifaoui qui est une caution scientifique
évidente qui est un expert reconnu du
sujet personne ne peut le remettre en
cause
il est pas apprécié par certains
apprécié par d'autres ça n'a aucune
importance qui compte c'est son
engagement c'est la qualité de ses
connaissances c'est son courage et je
tiens à le dire là clairement
j'ai beaucoup d'estime pour ce monsieur
qui se protection policière depuis 20
ans
il parce que il a risqué sa vie en
infiltrant une cellule de la Kaïda et a
continué malgré les menaces de mort
malgré le fait que sa vie était
bouleversée a porté cet engagement ce
combat là je pense que peu de personnes
sont capables en conscience d'engager ce
type de démarrage pour ça que beaucoup
d'estime pour
le combat qui est le sien et et donc je
considère que c'est une il fait autorité
dans ce champ là donc le fait de voir
apparaître monsieur Sifaoui dans le
portage de ce projet
il y a une caution scientifique claire
majeure et donc tous ces éléments là
font que il me paraît pas absurde de mon
point de vue que parce que je n'ai pas
encore parlé du projet cette association
puisse bénéficier du soutien de l'État
pour porter ses actions là
et après il y a la question du projet
par lui-même
on va y venir moi c'était important
d'avoir cette cette première analyse
donc ce premier contact avec Monsieur
CIF à oui vous l'avez quoi sur cette
histoire du livre là voilà non non
pardon pardon c'était un autre c'était
une autre personne
vous savez celui qui m'a invité à faire
un cours de boxe
c'est par ce monsieur que c'était passé
il m'avait sollicité parce que ça paraît
dans la presse m'avait sollicité
pour me présenter son livre puisque nous
travaillons d'accord ouais si j'ai sur
ces questions là et voilà donc sans
savoir que c'était l'ucpm parce qu'à qui
ne le présentait pas comme cela il
m'avait dit qu'il était responsable
associatif qu'il avait ce projet là mais
bref en remettant tout à plat en
revoyant tout cela je comprends donc
qu'il y a de toute façon aussi un lien
qui s'inscrit dans la durée sur ces
questions il y a la radicalisation
s'attaquer de jeudi de 2016 très bien
revenons-en au document de réponse à
l'appel à projet donc qui jusqu'à plus
en plein formé mais nous allons être
mieux informés qui ne fait qu'une page
donc à l'époque c'est quand même est-ce
que c'est sur cette base là c'est à dire
d'une page parce que vous pouvez avoir
eu des éléments complémentaires par la
suite et comme ça va très vite vous avez
une semaine
donc ce dossier est-ce qu'il fait partie
des dossiers qui rentrent qui rentrent
dans le fond Marianne alors qu'ils
auraient pu avoir une autre type de
subvention parce que il me semble qu'on
a vu quelque part que
le document avait été envoyé avant la
date ah oui alors déjà d'une part
c'est-à-dire mais ce qu'on envoie ce
qu'on envoie pas ce qui arrive pas c'est
juste vous pourriez venir là voilà de
même peut-être c'était plus loin je ne
sais pas c'est ce point-là mais je peux
peut-être par rapport à cela je ne peux
que le regretter profondément ayant en
tête que je pense que ça n'arrive pas
tous les jours au sein d'une
administration au-delà des quelques
politiques publiques que nous menons que
je rappelais en propre introductif et je
n'ai pas balayé de manière exhaustive
nos missions il y en a d'autres
qui sont toutes lourdes
nous avons eu en même temps
et par le hasard et par rapport à
l'actualité qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui des demandes de documents
conséquent la Cour des comptes de l'igéa
de l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat et
donc non attendez je ne dis pas que
n'empêche que
je ne veux surtout pas sous-estimer le
fait que je regrette très sincèrement le
fait que vous n'ayez pas eu ce document
de 6 pages ça on l'a pas non mais je
constatait après et du coup vous allez
si vous voulez bien garder la question
que je vous ai posé pour plus tard ce
qu'on va la on va on va leur faire dans
on va y revenir un peu plus dans le
détail excusez-moi sur la question de la
temporalité on y reviendra on y
reviendra alors sur le flow sur le
projet d'abord donc vous nous dites bien
alors à quel moment pour lire autrement
à quel moment vous avez des éléments
complémentaires avant la prise de
décision je fais simple parce que si
c'est pour les avoir après la prise de
décision
ça peut surprendre est-ce que vous les
avez donc dans la semaine la fabuleuse
semaine où tout se passe
ce dossier complet complet donc en
prenant également ce document que vous
auriez dû avoir entre vos mains depuis
quelques semaines j'ai bien compris
ce dossier complet il est envoyé
quelques jours avant le comité de
programmation du 13 avril
vous avez répondu on le reçoit ce stade
on le ressent à ce moment là et c'est à
la demande du cabinet
que ce dossier là rentre glisse vers
l'appel à projets on va plutôt l'étudier
dans le cadre du fond Marianne voilà
alors que je boucle la tube
définitivement Alma à l'occasion du côté
de programmation il est décédé de verser
la donc il y a même pas de débats dans
le sens il y a pas de débat bien sûr
qu'il y a des échanges mais tout est
ficelé tout est clair donc hop Alma ça y
est c'est acté on part comme d'habitude
comme chaque année dans le cas de
subvention étant donné la qualité leurs
projets ce dossier porté par l'uspm il
est complet et il est voilà il est
ensuite glisse vers le fond Marianne
quelques jours plus tard d'accord alors
un mois plus tard pardon puisque
de sélection toujours de cette
association
aviez-vous connaissance d'identité de
ces personnes qui allaient être
rémunérées par la subvention est-ce que
autrement dit je le fais autrement je
vous le dis plus clairement me
semble-t-il
est-ce que vous avez le CV des
intervenants en dehors de Monsieur
Sifaoui
mais qui est connu qui est connu de vous
qui est connu de beaucoup ici par
ailleurs sur ces interventions est-ce
que pour les autres vous avez leur CV à
part monsieur cifaoui qui a le rôle de
directeur de projet oui il me dit
lui-même qu'il devrait
toucher une partie de ces subventions à
travers un salaire
qui me paraît pas scandaleux étant donné
le rôle qui est le sien pendant cette
période là je n'ai pas connaissance de
l'identité de ceux qu'on vocation à
alimenter l'équipe
il y avait 6 et TP qui était qui était
prévu six postes étaient étaient
envisagé et pour répondre très
directement à votre question je ne sais
pas que le président l'association a
vocation à avoir le rôle de directeur
administration financier et je précise
que
je crois pouvoir le dire qui n'est pas
du rôle de mon administration d'aller
regarder contrôler ce qui se passe au
niveau des individus convocation à
travailler au sein de l'association ça
c'est il me semble que ça relève plutôt
d'autres services
mais pas du bien ce qui compte pour moi
c'est que l'association
quelle qu'elle soit je pense que ce
travail de contrôle en l'occurrence
relève du Trésor de la Cour des comptes
si nécessaire mais nous n'en n'avons pas
vocation à demander le CV comme vous
l'avez dit explicitement de ceux qui ont
vocation à travailler dans l'association
nous on a vérifié la qualité on a un
projet on reçoit un projet qu'on
considère comme étant hautement
qualitatif on va y revenir
il est il donne tout ça satisfaction en
tout cas sur le papier étant donné ce
qui apparaît on sait qu'il y a 6
personnes qui doivent être salariés dans
le cas de ce projet point à part le fait
que le directeur de projet est identifié
clairement pour le reste ce n'est pas le
cas il me semble que c'était 10
d'ailleurs au départ peut-être il y a eu
non
il y avait 10 salariés au départ
peut-être qu'il y en a eu que 6 qui
reviennent réellement réellement mais je
crois que sur la feuille de présentation
en fait c'était celle qu'on a eu
excusez-moi des revenus
insistez sur mon étonnement pour le
moins sur la question du de la seule
page comme vient de le dire le présent
que nous avons reçu jusqu'à maintenant
parce que vous ne m'empêcherez pas de
penser
qui a une espèce de conjonction
interrogative d'événements qui nous fait
constater aujourd'hui que on va avoir
davantage de pages sur ce document parce
que la question ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui et je crois deviner que
vous faites enfin certains seraient
envieux de dépendre pour des
attributions de soutien public de l'état
de
votre comité interministériel parce que
envoyer une seule page et avoir
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
de subventions
ça paraît quand même aujourd'hui assez
inapproprié
je vais revenir sur monsieur cifaoui
dont je note qu'il est donc un
journaliste rémunéré par l'USPPM
et pour ne pas
prendre moins de risque par rapport à la
réalité je voudrais que
on se comment dirais-je on se plonge
dans le communiqué qu'il a publié sur
Twitter le 12 avril dernier lorsque un
certain nombre d'informations sont parus
dans la presse et à ce moment-là il
déclare je n'ai pas pris cette
initiative spontanément j'ai été
encouragé par de représentants des
pouvoirs publics notamment par les
membres du cabinet madame Schiappa et
par elle-même je suis donc quelque peu
scandalisés en constatant qu'elle
participe gentiment ou lynchage en
feignant de ne pas me connaître et de ne
pas connaître l'association ce sont les
membres du cabinet de Marlène Schiappa
qui ont insisté pour que je prenne part
à la riposte citoyenne
la question que je souhaite vous poser
c'est avez-vous eu connaissance de cette
demande du cabinet ou de la ministre ou
des deux
avant de vous répondre monsieur le
rapporteur sur ce que vous avez dit
précédemment
avec je vous avoue mon incompréhension à
ce que vous preniez en considération le
fait que nous aurions pris ces décisions
d'accorder une subvention majeure à
cette association là uniquement sur un
feuillet je vous précise je vous le
redis formellement j'ai bien et je vous
le dis solennellement puisque je vois
bien ce qu'on peut en tirer comme
conclusion derrière sauf que je me
permets d'insister sur le fait que
même si je le regrette plus que
profondément vu l'importance de votre
assemblée ici vous auriez dû recevoir un
autre document qui nous a permis en
conscience de prendre cette décision il
ne s'agit en aucun cas d'un feuillet de
quelques lignes qui auraient débloqué un
claquement de doigts 300 50 000 euros
donc j'insiste lourdement pardonnez-moi
et puis parce que comme vous l'avez
rappelé et que je vous avais répondu je
ne peux pas laisser passer ça pardonner
moi mais je il y a eu un document fourni
des arguments qui ont permis ensuite de
notre côté
c'est à tout le moins une erreur ou une
faute hautement regrettable de nous
tenons nous en là pour l'instant
j'entends bien et je vous dis que je ne
peux que le regretter très sincèrement
mais vous avez aussi compris le contexte
dans lequel les éléments vous ont été
transmis et je pense que vous pouvez
aussi entendre qu'il peut y avoir une
erreur humaine dans ce cadre là
concernant donc cette dernière question
je vous rappelle ce que j'ai évoqué à
quelques minutes
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone fin avril
de Monsieur Sifaoui me disant que il
sortait du bureau de la ministre
déléguée qui lui avait parlé de son
projet
d'engager ce qui allait s'appeler
quelques jours plus tard le fond
Marianne à l'époque il y a pas encore de
d'attitude
ça peut pas être fin avril si si c'est
fait un vrai il m'appelle il m'appelle
fin avril d'accord
à pardonnez-moi pardonnez-moi fin mars
puisque le dossier est étudié en avril
donc avant le 20 avril fin mars
pardonnez-moi fin mars je reçois un coup
de téléphone de monsieur cifaoui me
disant il sortait du bureau de la
ministre délégués qui lui présentait
le projet en perspective
et lui-même relatant le fait qu'il était
pleinement satisfait de savoir qui
allait avoir un projet de ce type là
avec
des subventions permettant justement de
porter des projets d'envergure dans le
champ qu'on évoque depuis le début
je sais aussi qu'il y a eu des réunions
c'est ce qu'il m'avait dit à l'époque
avec effectivement le cabinet de la
ministre délégué
sur peut-être d'autres sujets aussi bien
sûr puisque encore une fois c'est un
expert reconnu mais probablement les
mêmes personnes que celles que vous avez
évoquées tout à l'heure
oui c'était parce que de toute façon
c'était ces personnes là qui suivaient
ces sujets là donc en toute logique et
donc voilà le fin mars l'appelle que je
reçois
précisant ce qui se trame avec le fond
Marianne à très court terme et le fait
que
on lui a demandé de réfléchir à un
projet
ambitieux en fait il est mis dans les
starting blocks on lui demande de
candidater avant même le c'est
clairement ce qu'il me dit il me dit
clairement que un c'est une bonne
nouvelle et donc évidemment il va il va
il va s'engager dans ce projet là et
vous l'avez vérifié auprès du cabinet
tout de suite enfin je veux dire vous
avez le cabinet qui vous dit le je vais
le faire au nom de la ministre je fais
simple pour rappel le cabinet pour
savoir de quoi il retourne le cabinet on
a quelques jours plus tard réunion et on
est début avril et là on commence à
parler du fond Marianne donc c'est là où
je comprends que tout ça est en train de
cette manière là et le projet de
Monsieur Sifaoui est évoqué à plusieurs
reprises je vous rappelle qu'il est
évoqué à l'occasion du comité de
programmation du du 13 donc voilà
il s'avère que dans cette association la
part du des salaires au regard des
charges et nettement plus élevé que pour
la plupart des autres associations
est-ce que vous avez trouvé ça normal
est-ce que ça vous a éventuellement
alerter
est-ce que c'est comment dirais-je
conforme
à l'esprit et du cahier des charges
l'objectif était de faire en sorte
on rentre dans le
projet
je précise que c'était le projet le plus
ambitieux le plus courageux
qui était le seul à engager à envisager
une confrontation directe avec des
activistes extrémistes
c'est le seul projet qui le fait et je
pense que je n'ai pas besoin de
m'attarder encore sur le degré de
connaissance de ces réseaux par ce
monsieur
qui donc encore une fois une caution
scientifique par rapport à ce projet et
l'essentiel de ce projet repose
objectivement sur la production
intellectuelle c'est que il s'agit
d'analyser de concevoir ensuite de
diffuser ces messages sur internet donc
je ne suis pas choqué par le fait que
une partie importante
de ces charges s'inscrivent dans dans
des dans des rémunérations puisque
précisément il s'agit de pouvoir payer
de l'intelligence à engager ce type de
travaux et je ne parle même pas bien sûr
du courage qui a été le sien le leur à
l'occasion des des productions qu'ils
ont pu faire puisque
même si j'imagine que vous pourriez me
poser la question mais il n'y a pas eu
que comme ça a été dit si ou là trois
vidéos avec 15 vues je comprendrais
évidemment dans ces cas-là
le caractère extrêmement problématique
dans ces cas là de des productions il y
a eu 500 premier produit par cette
association 3 500 contenus c'est pas
trois vidéos donc je on peut toujours
faire plus on peut toujours faire mieux
par définition mais ça c'était le
premier volet du projet ça établir je
vous interrompre une seconde 500 des
contenus mais quand vous nous
transmettez le bilan
comment dire à la fois financier morale
un peu de cette association mais on voit
pas 500 on va pas 500 contenus il y a eu
près de 500 tweets trade production qui
ont été
alors on va vous demander aussi si parce
que pour l'instant tout ce qui nous a
été transmis bon c'est franchement
quelques vues enfin c'est une rare
pauvreté je veux dire les choses donc
s'il y a du contenu vous avez des
documents si vous avez ces documents
pouvez-vous les joindre au premier en
m'excusant on va faire c'est moi qui
m'excuse on va faire en sorte s'il
s'agit pour faire les actions là encore
d'un élément que vous auriez dû avoir
que vous ayez absolument tous les tous
les éléments de de bilan parce que il y
a eu je vous dis sachant que tout ça est
au-delà de ce que affirme l'association
ce que nous-mêmes ont pu constater tout
ça est visible sur les réseaux sociaux
ou sur justement premier
premier volet de ce projet analyse de
l'écosystème puis ensuite riposte engagé
très régulièrement un rythme soutenu ça
a été fait c'est le cas
ensuite il y avait un deuxième volet
s'inscrivant dans la Constitution au
moins d'un site Internet puis d'une
encyclopédie numérique visant à agréger
tous les contenus permettant tous les
éléments d'analyse permettant de fournir
de la matière
aux internautes qui souhaitent eux-mêmes
s'investir dans cette démarche là pour
travailler agir interagir s'inscrire
dans ce travail d'influence en ligne en
connaissance de cause avec des éléments
de fond dans permettant de savoir que
quand on s'attaque au salafist
ou à cela faut djihadisme ou à la dérive
des Frères musulmans de quoi on parle
avec des éléments très précis si vous
voulez obtenir après moi j'aurais une
dernière question de
je dirais les factuels et de calendrier
et de manière de de
d'expliquer les contacts avant d'être
sélectionnés puisque je vois bien que
c'est aussi des éléments qui peuvent
apparaître
de second ordre mais
par les premiers constats que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur des documents qui
manquent je vais revenir sur les
échanges de courriels que vous avez
transmis avec l'usé ppm
qui vous a transmis donc personnellement
et directement ça candidature vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure et le
courriel qui vous est parvenu le 9 avril
c'est à dire 11 jours avant l'annonce et
le lancement de l'appel à projet donc je
rappelle que c'était 20 avril 10 mai
comment expliquer vous que vous ayez le
destinataire direct et personnel et
unique de cet envoi et est-ce que par
ailleurs sur cette même adresse vous
avez reçu des demandes autre d'autres
associations
et le cas échéant
comment expliquer vous quoi quel est
quel est ou quels sont les raisons qui
peuvent expliquer d'avoir des angoisses
sur direct et personnels quand le
l'ouverture la présentation officielle
est l'ouverture de l'appel à projet
n'est pas encore opéré
monsieur cifaoui lorsqu'il m'appelle en
sortant du bureau de la ministre me dit
que la ministre lui a précisé que ce
serait le cpdr qui gérerait ce type de
dossier et c'est donc je pense sur je
pense c'est pas la garantie que c'est
sur recommandations de Monsieur Siffredi
que le président l'association m'envoie
directement le dossier
et c'est donc le seul que vous avez eu
pour aucune autre association ne vous
envoyez avant le 20 avril de demande
pour pouvoir postuler au fond Marianne
je n'ai pas reçu d'autres associations
dans le cas du fond Marianne mais j'ai
reçu j'ai reçus assez régulièrement des
mails de président d'association qui
peuvent me parler évoquer me relancer
sur des questions de subventions se fait
régulièrement or pour Marianne
bien on poursuit sur le projet donc
de cette association alors justement
tout à l'heure on ouvrait la question 10
6 bons etc salarié ou peut-être pas ça
arrive à temps complet mais bon voilà
4,8 au TP donc c'est c'était si salarié
sur l'équivalent donc 4,8 et équivalent
en plein jusqu'à ensuite la réalité vous
l'avez vu c'est plutôt 3
trois salariés à deux à mi-temps assez
significativement rémunéré et 3 bon
voilà donc ça a beaucoup bougé mais en
particulier il y a eu une rectification
pour passer donc justement de 10
salariés à 6 salariés elle a été faite
postérieurement à l'accord pourtant elle
a pas amené à une modification du projet
de convention aurait pu penser que en
moyenne baissé je peux dire
subventions baissé je caricature mais
est-ce que
ça a été relevé est-ce que ça fait
l'objet d'un échange avec l'association
pour voir quel impact pouvait avoir sur
le résultat ou finalement non
nous n'avions pas connaissance que de
cet élément-là au moment où les choses
se passent c'est-à-dire que c'est un
posteriori lorsque dans le cadre du
contrôle apostériori on comprend qu'il y
a eu moins de salariés que prévu et
pendant les opérations cette information
ne nous remonte pas en tout cas je crois
pouvoir le dire ça ne remonte pas à mon
niveau et je pense que si c'était à
monter au niveau de mon équipe mon
équipe on aurait parlé pourtant c'est
dans le relevé CERFA qui vous a été
envoyé pour un peu le document officiel
d'engagement si je puis dire là par
contre on est à 6 mais on n'a pas de
connaissance que finalement ça va être
dans les faits ça va être réduit et
encore ça a été réduit à trois après
c'est encore précisé c'est encore pire
factuel donc 10 6 3 mais quand on passe
à 6 c'est sur le CERFA autrement dit le
document qu'on vous renvoie pour pour
comment dire toucher les faux et donc là
oui il aurait pu y avoir une petite
alerte petite alerte sur le fait que ça
avait été déjà modifié une fois quoi
pardon moi je pensais que vous me
parliez du 6 à 3 c'est possible
très bien
[Musique]
alors continuons avec le contrôle sur
pièce de cette association qui a été
menée donc
postérieurement il a donc été annoncé
seulement le 17 mars 2023 à
l'association
alors qu'il s'agit de la première
association en termes de montant des
subventions je le dis encore une fois si
tout avait été versé
d'ambiguïté et que l'association ne
répondait pas aux mails de relance
depuis plusieurs mois il y a plusieurs
mois de blanc
sur cette question et pourtant le
[Musique]
finalement le lancement
de du contrôle sur pièce il est fait
tardivement
alors tardivement si tu n'appréciation
que je fais évidemment mais surtout il
est fait avant d'autres d'autres
associations sont contrôlées avant qui
ne pose pas de problème et qui ne
relèvent pas a priori sur lequel vous
n'avez pas relevé de difficultés
particulières alors qu'avec celle-là
vous relevez des difficultés des
difficultés que vous relevez en réalité
sans un premier temps qu'on soit on vous
répond pas soit on vous répond que
finalement les sommes n'ont pas été
engagées un point tout à fait tout à
fait important sur lequel on va revenir
parce que tout à l'heure vous avez dit
mais vous me contredisez
éventuellement vous nous avez dit mais
on n'a pas engagé la deuxième partie on
a pris la décision de pas engager la
deuxième partie c'est ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure mais pour quelle
raison précisément pour celles que vous
avez évoqué
c'est qui à partir d'un certain nombre
de relances
considérés comme étant trop élevé
n'ayant pas de retour ou que partiel sur
les demandes qui sont faites en matière
de contrôle sur des pièces qui doivent
nous être remises dans le cadre du
processus de contrôle de l'action
nous avons pris la décision de ne pas
verser la deuxième tranche et à partir
du moment où ces décisions est prise le
secrétaire général adjoint appelle le
président
il tombe sur le président de
l'association et dans le cadre de
l'échange
monsieur Lafitte que vous allez recevoir
bientôt comprend aussi et lui-même
constate que de toute façon le seuil des
60% du budget prévisionnel n'avait pas
été atteint donc de toute façon il
n'aurait pas eu cette deuxième tranche
sa deuxième tranche n'aurait pas été
versée mais avant même de prendre
conscience qu'il y avait cette question
de critères budgétaire la décision était
prise étant donné les difficultés
auxquelles nous étions confrontés nous
avons recensé tous les appels exhaustifs
de manière exhaustive qui ont été faits
par notamment l'agent du pôle métier qui
est assuré le suivi
et jusqu'à présent les choses s'étaient
passées de manière on va dire à peu près
correcte et là il y a
une période qui correspond à la période
de contrôle apost ayurie où les choses
se compliquent
je vous interromps comment vous
comprenez ce 60%
c'est quoi ce niveau des 60% 60% de quoi
du budget du budget total du budget
prévision du total l'idée c'est que si
c'est pas 60% de la subvention donc
60% non c'est 60% de la subvention
pardon
60% de la subvention oui mais dans la
réalité cette opération en fait de cette
association comprend un budget général
qui n'est pas que fondé sur votre
subvention il y a d'autres d'autres
financeurs il y a des co-financeurs qui
finalement semble-t-il on a peut-être
pas tous les documents mais il
semble-t-il excusez-moi c'est normal je
ne pourrai pas faut approcher bon de
vous moquer
je vais essayer de pas le faire non non
c'est les choses sont sérieuses et je
vais pas essayer de faire mais bon non
mais dire simplement que pour que tout
le monde comprenne bien c'est pas la
question c'est pas une subvention et sur
cette subvention
l'association ne pouvons pas prouver
d'avoir dépensé plus de 60% on peut pas
lui donner le complément c'est pas
exactement comme ça c'est en réalité
cette
opération au sens large et de doit
trouver des co-financeurs
en particulier je crois des
collectivités territoriales de région de
région en réalité on sait pas ce qui se
passe mais à l'instant on voulait
questionner ces cofinanceurs n'existe
pas enfin c'est cofinancement n'existe
pas et du coup l'opération se bloque
parce qu'effectivement ils peuvent pas
justifier de 60 % de la totalité du
financement et à partir de là ça bloque
votre subvention mais je veux dire c'est
pas une décision si je peux me permettre
pas une décision juste par rapport à
votre subvention c'est simplement que le
plan de financement total n'est pas en
fait réalisé et que donc ils ne peuvent
pas prétendre à une partie de subvention
supplémentaire parce qu'ils ont pas les
cofinanceurs est-ce qu'on est d'accord
alors
c'est très clair il me semble bien que
ce sont les 60% de notre subvention
et il se seuil n'est pas atteint
et ce que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
Président est important puisque le fait
de voir apparaître dans le dossier
que deux co-financeurs de poids c'était
deux régions
Île-de-France et Nord pour pas les citer
contribuer à la solidité du dossier et
je vous confirme apparemment
le soutien n'a pas été apporté par ces
pistes ou ces liens qui avaient pu être
établis dans le cadre de la préparation
de ce dossier de leur côté
bref mais en tout cas non je me semble
bien qu'on est sur 60% de la subvention
que nous avons que nous avions
l'intention de d'accorder à l'entité
associative et donc les 60% n'ayant pas
été atteint nous avons encore une fois
de toute façon nous ne pouvions même si
nous ne pouvions pas en respectant cette
règle leur remettre cette deuxième
tranche mais je vous dis la décision de
ne pas la remettre relève d'abord du
constat qu'il y avait un
dysfonctionnement en termes
d'information de leur côté
merci on a on a
une lecture un peu différente
mais voilà enfin c'est peut-être une
question purement technique mais on
considère que les 60% c'est par rapport
à l'ensemble de l'objectif il fallait
d'abord démontrer d'avoir engagé plus de
60% du projet pour qu'ensuite il y ait
la possibilité de de financer le
supplément simplement quand on quand on
reste sur le sur ce sujet là au final on
se retrouve avec
à 60% on se retrouve avec 80% papa dire
plus de salaire c'est à dire que
évidemment ça déforme totalement
totalement l'enveloppe c'est à dire que
la subvention à la financé du salaire à
80% peut-être même un peu plus et
finalement il y a plus rien pour les
actions je fais simple sauf à considérer
que c'est que de l'action intellectuelle
mais ce n'est pas vrai il y avait aussi
des contenus à faire technique voilà et
donc on est bien voyez on a déformé
complètement le système etc voilà
quelques éléments que vous voulez un peu
discuter avec vous mais on va poursuivre
oui c'est sûrement les moi j'interprète
peut-être trop vite pour l'instant mais
c'est sûrement les raisons pour
lesquelles on a du mal
à ce que cette association enfin
j'observe a du mal à vous envoyer un
bilan en quantitatif que qualitatif
et en fait très peu de communication
entre cette association et
[Musique]
votre comité interministériel
entre mai 2022 et février 2023 alors que
vous avez je le redis demander un bilan
quantitatif et qualitatif vous avez
expliqué tout à l'heure que il y avait
de nombreuses relances
malgré alors malgré tout qu'est-ce qui
explique à ce moment-là s'il y a eu
beaucoup de relances qui est une absence
totale pas de signe de vie de
l'association qui pourtant a trois
salariés bien sûr qui pourtant connaît
ou alors peut-être aurait-il fallu moi
je vais être un peu rotateur peut-être
aurait-il fallu demander à la ministre
d'appeler directement son contact
alors je ferai pas je ferai pas je ferai
pas de commentaire à cette dernière
remarque
il me revient pas de commentaire
justement on avait eu les moyens d'avoir
un échange très clair on aurait pu le
savoir en détail ce qu'on comprend ce
qui remonte à ma collaboratrice
concernée c'est que le président est en
train de fonder une société qui lui
prend beaucoup de temps et donc il a il
est très compliqué de pouvoir le joindre
honnêtement ces arguments étant assez
faibles et surtout vu la répétition des
relances que nous faisons
c'est une finalement c'est une espèce
d'extinction des feux alors pour aller
dans dans votre sens est-ce qu'on essaie
de tenir on a quand même une autre
audition moi je vais être assez factuel
donc à des documents sont finalement
adressés le 15 février 2023
l'association a indiqué dans son projet
qu'elle recevrait un financement de 145
000 euros des régions et 45 000 euros
d'aide privé ou pluriel
aucune de ces recettes n'apparaît le
fond Marianne est finalement sa seule et
unique ressources
sur les charges beaucoup sont
sous-exécutés quand on est dans la
catégorie autre service extérieurs il
était prévu
177100 euros le chiffre réalisé un peu
moins de 31000 euros soit un taux
d'exécution de 17 %. alors que
l'essentiel des dépenses de cette
catégorie devrait être finalement des
dépenses de publicité de publication etc
on s'aperçoit que la plupart des
dépenses ont été là c'est pas basculé
dans rémunération intermédiaire et
honoraires et donc c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure les charges de personnel
s'élèvent à 87% pour l'année 2022 est-ce
que finalement l'objectif de la
subvention qui n'est pas modique
attribuée et bien atteint dans ce cas
d'espèce Monsieur le Secrétaire général
en fonction de ce que vous venez de dire
et prenons en considération ces éléments
d'analyse que nous avons opéré à notre
niveau dans le cadre de notre contrôle a
posteriori nous avons pris un certain
nombre de mesures
avec je l'évoquais à l'instant déjà
d'une part par définition vu les
problèmes pour recueillir ces documents
le refus au de la même de la situation
budgétaire de verser cette deuxième
tranche le fait que nous ayons engagé
un contrôle de 2e niveau un contrôle
facultatif sur pièce en prenant tous les
bulletins toutes les toutes les factures
permettant d'effectuer par notre pôle
administratif et financier en
particulier notre contrôleur interne
financier un point très précis
permettant de distinguer ou si oui ou
non il y a eu un certain nombre d'abus
qu'on peut être opéré enfin je vous le
rappelle le fait que
nous avons engagé j'ai engagé
personnellement un article 40 et étant
donné les éléments convergents nous
laissant penser qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre de problèmes en matière de
comptabilité et donc on peut dire que
sur ce avec cette association
comment dirais-je tout ça paraît très
léger si on nous est on dirait très
light ce que finalement
si on fait un très court résumé un
contact je pense d'une connaissance avec
la ministre de l'époque qui a porté sur
les fonds baptismo le fond Marianne qui
appelle une connaissance qui la prévient
avant vous êtes prévenus
cette personne candidate elle est
choisie une importante très importante
subventions comparativement à d'autres
est accordée et ça finit avec bien des
difficultés pour justifier à la fois
d'action mais surtout avec un constat
87% sont des dépenses de personnel et
vous menez une comment dirais-je une
démarche administrative article 40 voilà
oui moi je voudrais juste remettre au
clair cette article 40
si on regarde toutes les procédures il y
a une procédure qui est très clarifiée
avec des délais qui sont donnés
notamment
l'association a jusqu'en haut jusqu'au
mois de novembre 2022 pour donner
l'ensemble des éléments on en est loin
il donne quelques éléments avant et puis
plus rien très bien enfin donc ça fait
un moment que même en attendant des
limites par courtoisie ou en tout cas
par respect de la convention novembre
2022 lorsque l'article 40
pas l'article 40 ça c'est un vieux reste
c'est une question plutôt de prise en
commission des finances RT40 mais
lorsque vous lancez le procédure article
vous êtes déjà quatre mois après
et il y a deux aspects à la lecture mais
on laissera commenter premier aspect
on peut pas dire qu'il y a pas de lien
entre les interrogations de quelques
journalistes qui déjà vous contactent
dans cette période-là et le sujet déjà
sur la table si je puis dire des
ministres et d'autre part vous répondez
en réalité si je crois si j'ai bien
compris la presse à une demande de la
ministre vous demandant de de faire ce
signalement est-ce que c'est bien
l'effet
je rappelle que la démarche le process
de contrôle est engagé avant qu'il y ait
cet emballement médiatique
oui mais avant très peu avant mais avant
mais c'est important question de jours
peut compter dans ces cas-là donc c'est
important donc on n'a pas attendu que
une partie de la presse se focalise sur
le sujet pour engager toutes les
procédures de contrôle toutes les
procédures de contrôle ont été engagés
sur toutes les associations depuis le
début et je vous le disais en
introduction quel que soit la charge de
travail de mon équipe tout a été fait
j'étais au niveau du signalement j'étais
plus sur le point du contrôle après sur
la question du signalement
cette
c'était une volonté à la fois de ma part
étant donné
que je suis par définition le
responsable administratif de ce projet
et je vous confirme appuyé par la
secrétaire d'État je vous confirme et
comme vous le savez la secrétaire d'État
elle-même a voulu faire directement pour
l'autre association qu'on va aborder
j'imagine juste après
très bien
donc simplement dans une synthèse que je
reprends un petit peu du rapporteur
finalement on part d'une opération si je
puis dire qui vient par la ministre
Schiappa
jusqu'à un dossier qui vous arrive à
vous avec l'idée
du cabinet notamment de le mettre dans
dans le fond Marianne et on termine par
finalement
celui que l'on a accepté
on finit par finalement faire un
signalement contre l'association en
question
ça c'est factuel
vous avez un jugement porté sur ça
comment vous vivez ça
il est évident que
cette situation est regrettable
c'était évident étant donné la nature du
sujet le contexte dans lequel il est
établi je vais aussi rappelé qu'un
travail a été réalisé
pas de malentendu quand je vous parle de
500 contenus il y a eu 500 contenus
produits
le travail a été fait il y a eu du
travail qui a été fait après le fait
qu'on est on soit confronté à tous ces
problèmes d'ordre comptable et financier
bien évidemment et plus que regrettable
est-ce qu'ils avaient le briquet
toujours en tant que rapporteur avait
une question ou pas
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président
vous avez dit je pense que la réponse
va soit vu ce que vous avez dit mais
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure que
c'était un projet que vous considériez
autrement
qualitatif c'est pour ça qu'il
vous y avez donné suite et aujourd'hui
notamment au vu du bilan qualitatif et
quantitatif de ce projet avez-vous la
même la même impression
qualitativement
qualitativement le bilan est positif
c'est objectivement la seule association
qui a fait ce pourquoi s'était engagé en
s'inscrivant dans la riposte contre des
acteurs qui sont pour certains dangereux
c'est la seule qui l'a fait frontalement
ça a été fait avec
toute la connaissance qui caractérise ce
qui avait vocation et ceux qui se sont
impliqués dans ce projet là donc
qualitativement je considère en toute
objectivité que le travail est de
qualité bien sûr que quantitativement on
aurait pu espérer plus de choses en
termes de production mais en termes
d'interaction de de nombre d'abonnés
mais je veux quand même profiter pour
rappeler une règle du web qui est que
quel que soit la nature du projet quel
que soit
sa pertinence son efficience il faut
toujours plus d'un an pour pouvoir
agréger une communauté numérique
considéré comme étant assez large et
solide il faut il faut du temps il y a
cette temporalité qu'on retrouve sur
tous les projets élément comparatifs
l'association Alma qu'on a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises qui comme vous l'avez
compris aussi dispose d'un soutien
conséquent pas simplement du cpdr à
produit un certain nombre de contenu de
grande qualité et bien écoutez les
premières années on arrive à des niveaux
à peu près équivalents en termes de en
termes d'abonnés en termes de personnes
qui suivent précisément donc ça c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aussi avec
objectivité
établir ce bilan sur la dimension
quantitative bien sûr qu'on attend plus
on veut plus et on espère plus mais mais
il faut aussi objectivement remettre
ce type d'action dans ce contexte là
avec les règles de cet univers là
qualitativement je considère que le
travail a été engagé était de grande
qualité il y avait ce projet
d'encyclopédie numérique qui n'a pas
abouti à la fois il y avait la
perspective justement on l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure monsieur le Président de
potentiellement en tout cas c'était la
volonté l'association d'envisager un
travail sur plusieurs années parce que
c'est une encyclopédie ça se fait pas en
quelques mois même si je sais que le
travail avait commencé j'avais demandé à
mon équipe de vérifier avec
l'association et il y avait eu des
échanges ou en tout cas au moins l'idée
que le travail était bien engagé le site
internet a été créé avec pareil des
articles des éléments de fond permettant
d'alimenter ceux qui ont vocation
derrière à engager ce type de travail
sur la toile donc voilà je vais être
objectif de ce point de vue là du bilan
je l'ai dit et par rapport aux
problématiques qui étaient rappelées par
monsieur le rapporteur
dans l'arrivée là bien sûr que c'est
bien sûr que c'est profondément
regrettable et maintenant la justice
sera son travail par définition
merci Dominique delège
merci monsieur le Président
secrétaire général vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure le fait que les statuts de
l'association
Usain ppm la tête 1901 1920 était
reconnu d'utilité publique
sauf erreur de ma part il n'y a plus
d'association à faire de la préparation
militaire depuis les événements de la
guerre d'Algérie
peut-être auriez pu vous poser la
question de savoir ce que pouvait bien
faire cette association depuis les
événements d'Algérie et pourquoi les
statuts n'avaient pas été mis en
conformité avec la nouvelle activité que
cette association vous a présenté un peu
être un peu étonné que vous n'ayez pas
regardé ça de plus près d'autant plus
que les associations reconnues d'utilité
publique relèvent du ministère de
l'intérieur elles doivent être
régulièrement contrôlées
deuxièmement vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure que la prestation qui était
apportée était majoritairement
intellectuelle
et pour autant vous nous avez expliqué
qu'il n'était pas dans votre
responsabilité vos compétences de
vérifier les CV des intervenants
j'en suis étonné parce que si
effectivement la prestation était
principalement intellectuelle il était
important de regarder qui allait
travailler et vous avez renvoyé en
disant c'est plutôt le domaine du fisc
ou de la Cour des comptes excusez moi
d'avoir une appréciation un peu
différente je crois que quand on verse
une subvention d'un tel montant on
regarde qui va être amené à travailler
pourriez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
sur ce point je vous remercie
je sénateur
deux choses concernant les statuts de
l'association
à ma connaissance elle dispose toujours
de la reconnaissance du ttu public ce
qui pour moi est précisément
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit étant
donné le gage de fiabilité relevant du
ministère dont dépend ce statut
est un gage de confiance bien sûr que
les statues auraient pu être modifiées
mais sincèrement je considère qu'il
relève pas de ma responsabilité d'aller
demander à l'association de modifier ses
statuts ce qui compte pour moi c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le fait
que cette association là travaille
depuis sur la question de la jeunesse
sur la question de la citoyenneté d'une
manière générale et j'évoquais très
concrètement
une action qui relevée de l'un des
responsables de l'association en 2016
sur la question du terrorisme de la
radicalisation donc je ne pense pas
qu'on soit hors sujet étant donné la
thématique générale
l'investissement de cette association là
à un moment clé de notre histoire
contemporaine en lien direct avec le
sujet et enfin le fait que on avait dans
le cadre de ce projet lié au fond
Marianne un expert reconnu qui a été une
caution forte scientifique de ce projet
et qui
suffisait à nous rassurer sur la qualité
des productions qui devaient être
engagées dans la foulée et je vous le
dis avec le recul qu'elle met
aujourd'hui je vous invite tout
simplement à les voir ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est toujours en ligne
il n'est pas donné à tout le monde de
pouvoir engager un tel degré et de
connaissance et de pertinence en termes
de riposte à part
par justement la capacité à maîtriser ce
sujet là et cette maîtrise de sujet
n'est pas donné à tout le monde il faut
une investissement une connaissance et
c'est évidemment le cas de ce monsieur
qui a travaillé une équipe et qui
visiblement à travailler avec ceux qui
étaient concernés correctement puisque
moi on a pu voir les productions et je
fais la distinction la part des choses
entre encore une fois ces éléments-là
depuis long et les éléments liés à la
question budgétaire ça c'est financière
c'est évidemment deux sujets de sujets
qui sont différents même s'il concerne
bien sûr la même association
merci Monsieur le Secrétaire général si
vous voulez passer on va essayer de le
faire sur un rythme un peu accéléré mais
sans rien négliger on va parler de d'une
autre association reconstruire le commun
une association qui a été créée
seulement quelques mois avant le début
de l'appel à projet et surtout très peu
de temps après l'annonce de la création
du fond Marianne il s'avère que en
réponse aux questions de Mediapart vous
auriez loué je cite l'intelligence du
projet et je cite à nouveau convaincant
et parfaitement structuré cette
association a par ailleurs bénéfié d'une
subvention dite de lancement en 2020 de
39000 euros sur l'enveloppe
radicalisation donc du fond
interministériel
de prévention de la délinquance
pouvez-vous nous indiquer dans quelles
conditions a été attribuée cette
subvention qu'elle en était l'objet et
ce qu'elle avait par exemple ou est-ce
qu'elle aurait pu avoir pour objet de
lui permettre en tout ou partie de
répondre à l'appel à projet du fond
Marianne
pour répondre à votre question je
propose de reprendre si les éléments que
vous avez vous-même évoqué sur la genèse
de la de la de la relation avec le cpdr
déjà vous faire prendre conscience que
c'est fin décembre 2020
que la présidente de l'association va
construire le commun
mes conseillers par un universitaire
reconnu et donc je prends considération
ce conseil et je rencontre cette
présidente associative
une femme dotée d'une grande
intelligence qui a une vraie conscience
sur l'ensemble des enjeux liés à
l'actualité
une vraie conscience républicaine et qui
je le rappelle
a fondé cette association deux semaines
après le drame du professeur Paty
je pense pas qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'associations qui se sont mobilisés
dans cette temporalité là attestant de
cette conscience républicaine très forte
en voulant et c'est le discours qui m'a
été tenu
apporter une vraie contribution à ce
délitement au sein de notre société en
voulant apporter contribution
à la nécessité précisément de défendre
l'essentiel à savoir nos principes
et me présentant son projet elle
m'envoie dans la foulée une demande de
subvention
que nous acceptons de à laquelle nous
acceptons de répondre à hauteur de 39000
euros
correspondant à la fin de l'année 2020
pour pouvoir lui donner les moyens de
mettre en place un dispositif
permettant d'engager tout simplement des
actions avec
un projet qui est déjà construit l'idée
de s'impliquer sur la question durée des
réseaux sociaux et du web
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous acceptons de d'accorder cette cette
subvention qui correspond encore une
fois même s'il a été versé en 2021 qui
est accepté à l'occasion de l'exercice
la fin l'exercice 2020
à l'occasion du fond Marianne
elle apprend comme beaucoup
d'associations que ce projet émerge et
candidate
d'elle-même
avec cette fois-ci un projet d'envergure
très ambitieux
qui permet
ici un projet assez conséquent mais je
suppose que vous l'avez eu aussi avec
une vraie pour le coup une vraie
vraiment il y a pas d'ambiguïté possible
véritable maîtrise de tout ce qui relève
de la communication digitale
d'ailleurs la directrice de projet avec
laquelle
l'équipe travaille est elle-même une
experte du marketing digital la
communication digitale et puis la
directrice de projet pardon du commun
et je tiens à préciser aussi au delà du
contexte au-delà de l'engagement évident
qu'il s'agissait du seul projet
ambitieux porté par des jeunes pour des
jeunes c'est que c'est la seule
association constituée de la tranche
d'âge qui nous intéresse le plus
ce qu'il a aussi est un élément nous
permettant de considérer étant donné et
les échanges la qualité des échanges
étant donné la qualité du projet que il
est envisageable d'investir sur ce type
de projet et puis
une partie de
cette association est
issu d'un collectif qui s'appelle on
vous voit qui a déjà travaillé et qui a
déjà démontré
la qualité intellectuelle qu'il a
caractérise concernant précisément
l'analyse et la riposte à des acteurs de
type séparatiste sur la toile d'accord
et juste une phrase pour terminer avec
une précision c'est que ce collectif on
vous voit avaient
parfois produit des contenus à caractère
politique et la condition qui est
évoquée à l'occasion du soutien du cipdr
à cette nouvelle association avant donc
le fond Mariana je parle de la première
subvention conditions sinequanone c'est
que il est toujours cette intelligence
sur les logiques extrémistes et qui est
pas un seul contenu à caractère
politique c'est une évidence quel que
soit les opinions des uns et des autres
d'accord qui ne me regarde pas ce qui
compte pour moi c'est la qualité du
projet
et donc c'est vous qui décidez
d'attribuer 39000 euros à cette toute
nouvelle association je vous rappelle ce
rapporteur que cette décision elle est
pas unilatérale il s'agit d'un collectif
à l'occasion du comité de sélection
comprenant six personnes et qui est
décidé validé par le directeur de
cabinet je précise aussi que la ministre
devait venir à ce comité de sélection et
que c'est finalement son directeur de
cabinet qui est venu c'est pour vous
situer l'importance du projet du point
de vue politique de la première
subvention parce que je ne parle pas du
fond Marianne j'ai cru que vous avez dit
ça relève du CPDG mais je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est le cpdr qui décide
de d'accord donc vous avez considéré moi
j'entends les éléments vous venez nous
montrer enfin à nos collègues le dossier
qui est constitué qui donc vous
convaincre
il s'avère que cette association ne
déclarait d'ailleurs au moment de sa
création aucun salarié et que le comment
dirige le projet ne prévoyait aucun
recrutement ces raisons pour laquelle je
vous ai interrogé sur la directrice de
projet parce que une association qui a
pas de salariés enfin il y a des actions
qui fonctionnent bien avec beaucoup de
bénévoles mais pas exclusivement et
quand on a ce type de enfin de des
montants aussi élevés je pense que il
faut aussi davantage de personnes
ressources et je crois savoir d'ailleurs
que par des mails un membre de votre
secrétaire général c'était
étonné et avait d'ailleurs
adressé aux membres de l'unité du
discours du contredisco républicain que
l'on confie une subvention d'une telle
importance cette fois-ci 330 000 euros à
une association qui ne disposait d'aucun
de ses membres pour en assurer le
pilotage et la gestion financière
est-ce que cette remarque et cet
étonnement vous le partagez ou pas
cette remarque déjà elle permet
d'attester que tout était clair libre en
termes d'échange en interne qui avait
pas de directives données elle déteste
que chacun fait son travail au sein de
mon équipe et que le secrétaire général
adjoint magistrat avec la rigueur qui
est le sied responsable de ce pôle
administratif et financier je vous son
rôle disant attention est-ce que est-ce
que on est sûr que
on agit de la bonne manière il joue
pleinement son rôle et on a ces échanges
je vous précise encore une fois que
cette décision au final est prise et
prise par ce comité de sélection je
reviens pas je reviens pas dessus ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que conformément
aux engagements qui ont été pris par
cette association qui était évidemment
toute jeunes et qui n'avait pas encore
de bilan
issus de la première subvention versée
étant donné qu'elle venait de se
constituer et qu'on sait à quel point il
faut quand même un temps limité minimale
pour pouvoir engagé déjà un certain
nombre d'actions donc c'était pas le cas
au moment du fond Marianne puisque
finalement puisque personne ne savait
que le fond Marianne allait se déployer
six mois plus tard au moment du fond
Marianne donc le projet beaucoup plus
ambitieux et proposé et je vous précise
qu'il a été suivi des faits on est
arrivé jusqu'à 27 salariés dans cette
association
ce qui démontre qu'il y a eu une
utilisation
incontestable des fonds conformes aux
plans de charge qui avait été acté de ce
côté là
avec là aussi on va sans doute en parler
dans la foulée un projet qui au moins
sur le papier on pourra peut-être
évoquer un certain nombre de ces
contenus et était là aussi conforme à ce
qui avait été pressé et conforme à tous
les codes du web aujourd'hui alors que
c'était l'une des conditions sine qua
non pour pouvoir engager un soutien de
l'État sur ce type de sujet vous avez un
peu anticipé dans les réponses mais ce
qui va me permettre de raccourcir et
d'aller plus au fait puisque vous avez
expliqué que de 0 l'association était
passé à 27 salariés et que un travail
important avait été fait mais il vous a
pas échappé que dans les éléments
transmis il y a un certain nombre de
prestations qui ont posé des difficultés
et d'ailleurs que l'association vous
vous y avez fait allusion il y a
quelques minutes
c'est livré des productions de contenus
à caractère politique notamment donc
semble-t-il dans une réunion qui a eu
lieu le 1er mars 2022 il lui était
demandé de cesser ce type de publication
est-ce que vous associez à cette réunion
pouvez-vous nous expliquer à la fois ce
qui s'est passé quels ont été les
directives et qu'elles ont été est-ce
qu'elles ont été respectées parce
queuleusement et à partir de quand le
projet comporte quatre volets
au total sur un an 57 vidéos produites
près de 24 heures de vidéo
l'agent l'agent chargé dans mon équipe
de d'assurer le suivi
avait effectué un certain nombre de
remarques sur les premiers contenus qui
avaient été produits
les principales remarques reposent
d'ailleurs sur
la spécialitative de manière générale
sur la nécessité sans doute de
retravailler c'est ce qu'ils ont fait à
chaque fois tous ces éléments en
considération ils ont retravaillé la
ligne éditoriale puisque nous étions
inquiets par le faible taux d'engagement
de ces contenus là et prenant
considération ensuite nos remarques il y
a eu effectivement un changement
stratégie avec notamment aussi un
investissement en matière de sponsoring
qui fait qu'ils ont pu sortir passer un
seuil et enfin engager un certain nombre
d'interactions sur sur le web
c'était ça le principal élément
maintenant en février fin février
l'agent chargé du suivi qui je le
précise
contrairement à la première période les
6 premiers mois ont été suivis par
l'équivalence que j'évoquais le chef de
projet la personne qui faisait que ça à
100% à temps plein
bénévolement ou salarié parce que j'ai
chez moi
la personne qui travaillait à 100% sur
le projet
et qui d'ailleurs je tiens saluer son
travail malgré la charge à su
s'organiser assurer un suivi
consciencieux c'est une vraie
professionnelle et donc au bout de six
mois elle est elle a quitté la structure
pour rejoindre une autre structure et
donc il y a eu ensuite une répartition
sur quatre agents de mon équipe et qui
donc eux-mêmes avaient déjà une fiche de
poste des actions à mener
à forti au sein de l'unité contre le
discours qui était en plein déploiement
parce que tout ça se passe au même
moment lutter contre le discours est
issu
du drame que nous avons évoqué
et donc il y a une attente très forte et
une pression très forte totalement
justifiée pression que se mettent
eux-mêmes les agents étant donné la
genèse de ce service et donc en
surcharge de travail chacun en doit une
partie de du suivi des associations qui
étaient initialement suivies par par le
chef de projet
donc l'agent qui se charge de du suivi
de 7 associations là de reconstruire le
commun repère je vous dis un certain
nombre de contenus sans doute à
améliorer
les critiques sont prises en
considération et le travail est avancé
effectué par l'association et en février
fin février elle se rend compte qu'il y
a eu trois trois quatre contenus à
caractère politique
elle m'a l'air immédiatement
je lui demande de convoquer
l'association ce qu'elle fait et l'agent
donc convoque l'association et il lui
fait part de ses remarques des éléments
qualitatifs que j'évoquais et de cet
élément hautement problématique
avec ces trois quatre contenus qui avait
été repérés la présidente de
l'association
prend acte de cette consigne extrêmement
claire et qui ne laissait doute à aucune
forme d'ambiguïté d'interprétation
c'était vous n'avez strictement pas le
droit
d'une manière ou d'une autre de vous
inscrire dans des contenus à caractère
politique
c'est acté par la présidente
c'est la preuve que cette actée par la
présidence c'est que nous avons au moins
une vidéo si c'est pas deux ou les
chroniqueurs de la du sous-projet
concerné sur les quatre un projet un
sous projet qui est hautement
problématique
eux-mêmes sous forme d'ironie se moque
de la situation disera mais attention
faut qu'on fasse attention à ce qu'on
dit parce que notre présidente qui
s'appelle Allam elle est très
sympathique mais si on continue à faire
ça sous-entendu sur continuer à parler
de politique elle va avoir des problèmes
donc ça veut bien dire que c'est
redescendu ça veut bien dire que 1 on a
effectué notre travail de suivi de
contrôle de l'action de le message est
passé et trois le message est même passé
en interne
après
à l'occasion
d'un autre visionnage que fait l'agent
concerné il se rend compte qu'il y a eu
à nouveau des contenus politiques et
dans ces cas-là je dis d'organiser une
réunion sous un président ou je les
convoque je voulais convoquer fin mai et
le seul créneau qu'on trouve c'est je
crois le 2 juin
ou là je suis très très clair très
explicite
sur le fait qu'il est intolérable qu'il
y ait ce type de contenu mais au moment
où je les convoque et au moment où je
leur parle
nous pensons qu'il n'y a que quelques
contenus encore à ce moment-là je vous
rappelle que l'agent concerné est
objectivement sur charge de travail il a
il regarde régulièrement les quatre les
quatre catégories de projets il y a pas
de souci dans les trois premiers et
celui-ci à la deux reprises elle
s'aperçoit qu'il y a eu cette personne
s'aperçoit qu'il y a eu quelques
contenus Catastro politiques et ce sont
quelques caractères à conduite de trop
c'est ce qui est évoqué très clairement
dans sa bouche déjà au mois de mars et
dans la mienne
de manière vigoureuse au mois de juin
j'ai bien conscience en plus de la
période dans laquelle on s'inscrit
électorale présidentielle et bien de
passer c'est législative
je connais un petit peu le code
électoral
donc je peux vous dire que
dire que je suis contrarié en colère est
un euphémisme
étant donné précisément ce que nous
avons collectivement investi sur ce
projet là pour le reste encore une fois
d'autres satisfaction il y a bien sûr
qu'il y a des choses à améliorer mais il
commence c'est innovant il y a des bons
c'est c'est conforme encore une fois ce
qui avait été présenté sauf là dessus
et lorsque
tout dernièrement et c'est trop tard on
s'aperçoit que il y a eu de nombreux
contenus caractère politique là dans ces
cas là évidemment on bascule et j'ai
engagé moi une démarche de procédure de
remboursement total ou partielle de la
semaine je crois qu'on va venir
c'est que nous avons recensé 10 pages de
Verbatim
concernant ces contenus problématiques
et ce qui est fondamental par rapport à
ce que j'ai pu lire ou entendre
c'est que au-delà du caractère
intolérable
qui ont s'inscrit dans une forme
d'insouciance et d'inconscience
de ces quelques jeunes ça concerne pas
toute l'association encore une fois
qui malheureusement
[Musique]
profiter de cette opportunité là dans ce
contexte là avec l'histoire de ce projet
là ce qui rend la faute d'autant plus
insupportable c'est que
dans ces 10 pages de Verbatim
on constate assez clairement
qu'il n'y a aucun contenu partisan
faisant la promotion de tel ou tel
candidat ou candidate que absolument
toutes les personnes politiques
concernées de l'opposition comme de la
majorité y compris le président de la
République
et vous pouvez vous-même si vous avez
envie de regarder regardez les 16 heures
de vidéo concernées je vous souhaite pas
mais si vous voulez le faire vous pouvez
le constater par vous même c'est que à
moins de faire preuve d'une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
évidente ou de s'inscrire dans une
orientation spécifique il n'est pas
concevable de considérer que ces propos
quel que soit leur caractère intolérable
à contribuer à la campagne de tel ou tel
candidat ou tel ou telle candidat
sur ce point ça relèvera pas de cette
commission d'enquête mais je me permets
de le dire de la situation est trop
sérieux on va pas aller plus loin sur ce
sujet
et je vous ferai juste moi une remarque
sur l'association j'ai rapidement
vérifié vous m'avez dit qu'elle était
passée de 0 à 27 salariés
a priori et Sauveur de ma part ça
n'apparaît pas clairement pour pas dire
pas du tout dans les contes de
l'association au titre de l'année 2022
donc
regardera ça je regarderai ça d'un peu
plus près voilà merci elle a eu jusqu'à
27 salariés mais avec des autres pièces
que manquerait pas nous envoyer le verbe
intime nous évitera combien vous dites
18h de 16h ou 16h ça dépend à quelle
vitesse on dit très bien
donc vous avez du coup avancé
vous avez avancé sur les sujets sur les
dates février juin mais
du coup on n'arrive pas à suivre alors
on a une association très bien qui fait
des choses bien et qui ont fait d'autres
plus délicates ça comme ça
il y a des réunions à pas de donc il y a
à la fois de l'appréhension du problème
assez tôt j'avais donné d'ailleurs dans
les pièces en février réunion en août
réunion etc parce que ça pas été suivi
des faits pour autant
là vous n'hésitez pas si je puis dire à
verser les 25% de subventions restantes
à l'association c'est-à-dire on a du mal
à voir le lien que vous faites entre les
problématiques et le fait que pendant
quand même quelques mois les choses se
poursuivent comme si vous aviez rien dit
je crois grossis peut-être un peu le
train mais bon et
donc malgré tout il vous présente la le
le la fin du financement et vous payez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
mystère il s'agit pas d'un mystère il
s'agit d'une situation qui s'explique
par le calendrier
précis l'enchaînement des des éléments
sur le volet critique concernant la
qualité de certains contenus je parle
pas des contenus politiques il y a un
certain nombre d'échanges entre le pôle
métier le pôle administratif financier
en interne aussi PDF
justement pour se demander si on pouvait
pas essayer de vous considérer
potentiellement
le versement de la deuxième tranche
et à l'époque je suppose que vous en
reparlerez avec Jean-Pierre Laffite
lui-même après qu'on ait pu échanger sur
le sujet
et le pôle financier considère que tout
est en règle d'un point de vue
budgétaire et financier c'est que toutes
les pièces ont été à chaque fois
transmises en temps en heure on a
dépassé le taux des 60%
par conséquent
le pôle administratif est financier
considère que si on envisage de ne pas
verser cette deuxième tranche il y aura
de fait puisque des montants importants
étaient engagés il y aura de fait un
contentieux et qu'il est évident que
nous perdons se contentieux puisque de
toute façon tout atteste que
l'ensemble du projet a continué à se
déployer tel que c'était prévu
initialement en respectant absolument
toutes les formes administratives et
budgétaires comptables
et le problème c'est qu'au moment on
procède décision on n'a pas connaissance
de toutes ces dérives il y a au cas au
contenu à caractère politique je vous
dis que jusque
jusqu'à dernièrement
jusqu'à encore quelques semaines où
c'était non il y a deux mois pardon
maintenant quelques semaines
nous n'avions pas perçu l'ampleur des
dégâts liés à ces contenus à caractère
politique parce que si nous avions
conscience et connaissances de cela à ce
moment-là il est évident que nous
aurions pu caractériser du fait même du
la violation ou la modification
substantielle du projet nous aurons pu
évidemment justifier de ne pas verser
cette deuxième tranche et par ailleurs
d'engager sans attendre des procédures
les concernant
très bien
cette temporalité là je vous dis
il y a au fait que l'agent qui assurer
le suivi avait objectivement une
multitude de de travaux à mener et sur
les 57 heures on a vu que quelques-unes
voilà et n'a pas repéré
n'a pas repéré le fait qu'il y avait de
nombreux contacteurs politiques au
moment où il y a eu ce suivi mais tout a
été fait à partir du moment on en a pris
connaissance tout a été fait évidemment
pour pour pouvoir
corriger rectifier ce qui doit l'être
très bien vous noterez encore une fois
que ça peut paraître
pour nous-mêmes surprenant d'avoir une
association voir qu'il y a des
difficultés qu'elles ont été levées par
par vous sans problème qu'elles ont
donné lieu à des remarques en tout cas
vous avez même dit des mises en cause
très claire enfin sur le sujet
Quels n'ont pas été suivies des faits
que malgré tout on a un surfinancement
de financement de 25% qui est versée et
puis que ça se termine après par une
procédure de remboursement vous pouvez
vous dire à quel moment cette histoire
de procédure de remboursement elle est
engagée à partir du moment où
nous prenons connaissance de ces dérives
à caractère politique
on parle de quelle période envisageons
d'engager ce processus là le processus
est engagé formellement la semaine
dernière quelques semaines après
ok on termine peut-être avec
pardonnez-moi monsieur le Président mais
vous imaginez que
de fait
nous n'avons collectivement aucun
intérêt nous n'avions qu'un intérêt à ce
que les choses se passent de cette
manière là aucun intérêt et donc ce qui
peut rien dans ce sens
[Musique]
je confirme que
je l'évoquais dans mes propos liminaires
on est dans un champ qui est
expérimental encore et
l'idée c'est ça va être dans le champ de
la lutte contre le séparatisme ou la
radicalisation on fait pas de Paris
c'est un champ on s'engage c'est un
engagement et nous considérions cabinet
comme administration que nous pouvions
faire confiance à cette association là
étant donné les gages qui nous étaient
donnés à ce moment-là étant donné la
nécessité pour nous d'essayer aussi de
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs
pouvant travailler sur ce sujet là
il y a bien une personne qui est
profondément affectée par cette
situation c'est votre serviteur mais
l'engagement comment dirais-je
l'interdit pas ni la sobriété ni la
rigueur
parce que vous voyez bien que finalement
on encourage une association nouvelle
finalement aujourd'hui vous êtes vous
êtes contraint de demander un
remboursement vous avez vous avez une
estimation du du remboursement que Vous
sollicitez la procédure était en cours
nous allons précisément déterminer très
rapidement le montant que nous pourrons
exiger une association c'est trop tôt
pour nous communiquer
une évaluation de ce que vous pensez
demander nous sommes effectivement en
train d'effectuer cette évaluation donc
je préfère pas vous donner le chiffre à
ce stade donc vous si vous pouvez nous
faire connaître bien sûr sachant que
vous savez qu'on a des délais
assez contraints bien sûr que c'est
trois mois maximum d'accord merci
et est-ce que vous je remarque enfin que
finalement
depuis
ces difficultés au titre de cette année
2023 nous semble-t-il dans tous les cas
nous n'avons eu aucune connaissance
d'échanges écrits entre
le cidpr et
PDF pardon et l'association
puisque le dernier échange écrit remonte
à novembre 2022 donc reconnaissez que ça
fait déjà un petit moment
comment expliquer vous cela vous venez
de vous dire
on va engager une
démarche officielle de remboursement
engagé j'ai compris la semaine dernière
en tout cas ce sont vos propos comment
expliquer vous cette
lenteur relative
il y a eu des échanges écrits entre
l'agent chargé du suivi et l'association
ça peut être des messages écrits envoyés
par par texto
par mail évidemment
et le fait d'envisager d'organiser des
réunions formelles avec des convocations
mais malgré tout de démontrer qu'il y
avait une volonté
préciser un cadre très clair pour faire
passer des messages tout aussi clair
concernant les dérives constatées à
différents niveaux
la démarche a été engagée écoutez
quelques semaines après avoir constaté
l'étendue de ces dégâts concernant les
contenus à Carter politique
que j'attendais à ce qu'on puisse
évidemment faire le point avec l'équipe
on l'a fait et tout est parti la semaine
donc pas d'écrit pardon c'est ma
dernière question président pas décrit
depuis
novembre 2022 sauf faire de ma part pas
de réunion formelle depuis juin 2022
vous nous confirmez ces éléments ce qui
veut dire que nous aurions besoin
d'avoir
communication des
traces des des comment dirais-je des
démarches que vous auriez pu
entreprendre puisque vous avez dit mail
sms même si le sms je sais pas quelle
est sa valeur juridique mais enfin bon
autant d'éléments qu'on est au moins un
faisceau d'indice convergent parce que
je ne vous cache pas que
il y a quand même des dans nos échanges
de cet après-midi à plusieurs reprises
ce qui moi je vous dis néanmoins
m'étonne
s'agissant de relations entre une
administration et des associations quand
on connaît parfois le contrôle qu'on
juge tatillon vis-à-vis d'administration
avec des budgets bien moindres voilà je
vous remercie
bien merci Monsieur secrétaire général
pour vous réponse
et nous reviendrons vers vous si des
réponses écrites complémentaires nous
semble nécessaire
vous aurez compris évidemment
on avait déjà un peu fait part mais
vous l'avez
reconnu que finalement sur
il y a deux projets un peu expérimentaux
on va dire ça comme ça sur des montants
significatifs les deux autres projets
sont des associations connues du fond et
sur les deux projets expérimentaux
l'infini par un signalement la deuxième
par une demande de remboursement c'est
sûr que bon
c'est une difficulté bien entendu
[Musique]
nous reviendrons vous pour des réponses
complémentaires sur les documents qu'on
a pu pointer ensemble sur des éléments
supplémentaires et le dernier qui vient
d'être précisé à l'instant et juste
avant qu'on se quitte ce qui est est-ce
que de votre côté vous avez des éléments
complémentaires à faire connaître la
commission d'enquête je voudrais
préciser que ces situations ne fait pas
rire
loin de là
vous précisez que
à travers une approche comparative il
faut prendre conscience que quand je
parle d'expérimentation ça pourrait être
apparaître comme une forme de d'agilité
à essayer de d'esquiver les problèmes
regardez ce qui se passe à l'échelle
européenne regardons ce qu'on fait nos
amis britanniques
britanniques ont été les premiers
engagés des actions contreditours
sociétal en ligne et ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont parfois commis des erreurs ils
ont même été jusqu'à financer des
salafistes quiistent considérant que
c'était le peut être un moyen justifié
d'annuler les dynamiques liées au
salafist djihadistes je vous laisse
imaginer les résultats et l'addition qui
a été prise par la suite en France en
les pouvoirs publics investissent sur
l'une des spécialistes soi-disant des
questions de radicalisation je crois
même que deux de vos collègues sénateurs
ont effectué un rapport sur le sujet
c'est un nom d'un certain nombre
d'éléments avec des montants très très
important sur une structure une personne
rappelons-nous pour tournis le centre
d'Eric et les Sion je suis pas en train
de dire ça pour esquiver quoi que ce
soit à commencer par mes responsabilités
je veux juste vous dire que confronter à
la réalité de ces phénomènes à leur
dynamique oui je revendique le fait que
nous devons envisager d'expérimenter
envisager de faire émerger des acteurs
des projets et les projets concernés
avaient toutes les garanties en termes
de structuration encore une fois de
pertinence d'analyse de connaissance des
codes d'Internet qui nous permettait de
considérer qu'on pouvait investir sur
ces sujets là la suite j'en fais pas
plus de commentaires je suis le premier
affecté je suis pas le seul et je suis
le premier affecté parce que précisément
je suis un serviteur de l'État et j'ai
trop conscience de la valeur à la fois
évidemment des données publiques et de
la nature et de la responsabilité qui la
nôtre par rapport à cette politique là
je tiens au passage pour finir dernier
mot à remercier les associations qui se
sont engagées vu leur courage je peux
vous dire que certaines sont pas très
bien après que la liste complète était
diffusée par certains médias certains
ont même pensé à arrêter les actions
considérant qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas
apparaître sous le saut de la lutte
contre le séparatisme et la
radicalisation
donc ça fait peur parce que précisément
ils savent ce qui se passe en termes de
cyber-racinement en termes de menaces et
je veux également finir par féliciter et
remercier mon équipe qui quel que soit
la surcharge a toujours su agir avec
professionnalisme rigueur et quel que
soit sa charge de travail à accompli sa
mission y compris dans le cas du suivi
du fond Marianne je vous remercie merci
Monsieur sur les terres générales et
pour mes collègues je rappelle que dans
3 minutes nous poursuivons et qu'ils
avaient l'amabilité de pouvoir rester
pour la deuxième édition ce serait
parfait merci